treatment of Revenue Administration and
anyone that you'd like to sit with you
you're welcome to come forward they're
opting to sit behind you
[Laughter]
they're smart
yes so Lindsay if you could state your
name for the record please and good
morning Mr chair members of the
committee Lindsey stepp commissioner at
the New Hampshire Department of Revenue
Administration thank you for having me
this morning you will have a handout
hopefully in front of you
um I'll go through my remarks and then
we'll kind of talk about we'll go
basically a county unit by accounting
unit through our budget so that your
familiar with everything that we have
going on 152 for the members so where it
can be found yes and I have also
included page numbers for each of the
accounting units as well as we move
through so that you're able to follow
along
and I will address some questions that
came up when we were here during our
meet and greet session and I'm also
prepared to answer some questions that I
know have come up about hb2 over the
past week or so so hopefully we'll have
a lot of fun this morning
this
all right good morning thank you for
allowing me the opportunity to present
the fiscal year 24 and fiscal year 25
Governor's operating budget for the
Department of Revenue Administration
with me today our assistant commissioner
or Lemire and business administrator
Shelly garlano both sitting behind me
um the mission of the dra is to fairly
and efficiently administer the tax laws
of the State of New Hampshire collecting
the proper amount of taxes due while
incurring the least cost to taxpayers in
a manner that merits the highest degree
of public confidence in our integrity
further we provide prompt and
constructive assistance to the municipal
units of government in matters of Budget
Finance and the appraisal of Real Estate
together we developed a thoughtful
operating budget that will provide the
resource resources for our team to
administer the tax laws of the state for
another two fiscal years in a manner
that is consistent with this mission
in fiscal year 2022 the dra collected
2.7 billion dollars in state revenue
with total expenses of less than 18.7
million some of which is for activities
unrelated to revenue collections such as
local assessment reviews and state aid
when those unrelated costs are accounted
for our cost of collection is just over
one half of one percent
the information included with this
testimony explains how we were able to
build a biennial budget that continues
to be an unparalleled return on state
dollar tax investment and we look
forward to working with you
moving on to the presentation
statement which I just read in my
opening remarks is on the second slide
on the third slide which looks like this
organizational chart
yep right there
so for the Department of Revenue
Administration fiscal year 22 and 23
organizational chart we have 156
authorized full-time positions there is
no change in the total number of
authorized positions for our 24 and 25
budget so we are not adding any
additional positions
those positions are broken down between
121 classified positions and 35
unclassified positions
and those positions fall in our
Administration unit audit division
collections division taxpayer Services
Division and Municipal and property
division I've included there the
accounting units that correspond to each
division and as I said we'll kind of
walk through those
um unit by unit to discuss the
Appropriations there
moving on to slide four
the fiscal year 2425 agency budget big
picture so you will see
um we have general fund education trust
fund and agency income the majority of
our budget is general fund dollars
the education trust fund money is to for
the Department to administer the low and
moderate property tax relief program so
those payments come out of the education
trust fund and then the agency income is
flood control which we will get to in a
little bit
then you have a total for all funds and
we're showing fiscal year 22 23 adjusted
authorized and then for 24 and 25 I've
included the agency request and then
what the governor has proposed
you will see when you're comparing total
funds from fiscal year 22 to fiscal year
23. the total funds of 18 just under
18.7 million of actual expense in 22 and
in 23
22.1 million the biggest difference
there is really due to our vacancy rate
our general fund operating budget is
about 75 salary and benefits so we are a
department of people not things or
programs we've been operating at about a
15 vacancy rate
um for probably close to the last 18
months so that's really the biggest
difference between our 22 actual and our
23 adjusted authorized
um you will see as I mentioned on the
previous slide that our total number of
positions remains static at 156
positions
um the funded position count has
decreased
um from 156 full-time classified and
unclassified positions in fiscal 21 to
150 in fiscal years 22 and 23 we did
request for those additional six
positions to be funded in 24 and 25
however the governor did not fund them
so we um the governor's budget remains
static at a funding 150 of our 156.
um positions
the budget generally includes sufficient
funding McGuire's sure you're going to
highlight those extra positions as we go
along I will that's right thank you
um the budget generally sufficiently
funds provides funding for employee
training out of state travel for our
audits overtime for Peak periods and
taxpayer services and collections
division maintenance of state-owned cars
for our in-state Audits and property
appraisal work and postage for Dra
Communications to taxpayers I will go
through accounting unit by accounting
unit and highlight areas but of
difference between the agency's request
and the governor's amounts and any
additional requests that we have
so going to page five we will start with
the administration accounting unit which
I noted can be found on page 152
the most significant differences between
our fiscal year 23 adjusted authorized
and the fiscal 24 and 25 amounts from
the governor occur in a few different
places
first in class 27 the transfers to doit
the increase here is due to a request
for funding for rims consultant so when
we came in previously to do our meet and
greet we talked about our Revenue
information management system it was a
30 million one hundred and sixty dollar
thousand dollar Capital appropriation
that Capital appropriation includes
Hardware maintenance and software
licensing through fiscal 25. but only
include software maintenance and
Consulting through the first quarter of
2024.
so the increases due to funding of six
consultants for the remainder of fiscal
24 and then five consultants for fiscal
25.
the reason why those amounts are not
included in the capital budget is
because we opted to not select
predetermined support for our post
implementation Consulting needs because
we didn't know what we would need and we
wanted to have the flexibility that a
time and materials
budget would allow us both in terms of
making sure we're only receiving exactly
what we need and to provide some cost
Effectiveness so at the time that we
went out to bid with this Capital
appropriation
we didn't know what we were going to
need and I didn't want to lock us into
either a amount of amount of Consulting
that was in excess of what we would need
and therefore could be a waste of money
or lock us into an amount of Consulting
that was not sufficient so now that
we've gone through the implementation of
rims and rims is active we feel
comfortable
with requesting the amount for six
Consultants as I mentioned in 24 and
five consultants in 25.
representative McGuire has a further
question yes thank you so it looks like
this line has an extra two million
dollars in it
um that's a lot for six Consultants
isn't it like four hundred thousand
dollars each or something that's right
um it is
it your math is right is it roughly four
hundred thousand dollars a year but it
is a time in materials contract so we
wouldn't necessarily be locked into that
amount that is the amount that we've
budgeted for each consultant arriving at
six but if we decide that we need less
than that then the time of materials
budget would give us the flexibility
so what I'm hoping to get to ultimately
is less Reliance on the Consultants I
want to shift that work to doit that's
embedded at dra
um and we're not totally ready to do
that just yet so I want to make sure
that we have a smooth transition rims
has been very successful as we've
mentioned up until this point
um it's been successful for the
department and for the taxpayers and so
I would like to get to a point where we
are maybe only looking at four
Consultants on site at times but we're
just not there yet so that's why you'll
see the request goes from six to five
because I do want to Trail down because
they are expensive
um but it is an important system it
brings in the vast majority of our
general and education trust fund Revenue
so it's just making sure that we find
that balance
man sure is the software proprietary in
some ways and such that the doit people
will never be able to
maintain it or something or not really
I it is proprietary but not to the sense
that they will never be able to maintain
it we've already started a nice
partnership where our folks work in
conjunction with the vendor Consultants
um there just needs to be some more
knowledge transfer there thank you I
have a question commissioner 30 million
dollars as far as the rims Consultants
it's a fairly large number when you said
you went out to bid how many people bid
on this contract we received two bids
um they're the two main players in this
field the bids in terms of dollars were
very similar
looks like you may have a question no
not yet okay
yeah and just to clarify if I made the
30 million dollars includes the
Consulting work but also the license for
the software and the hardware we have a
significant amount of Hardware that's
associated with it as well so the 30
million dollars was the whole bucket
the other place that you'll see
um an increase or a difference between
fiscal 23 and the 24 and 25 Governors
Amounts is in our equipment and in-state
travel and that increase is for the
purchase of new state cars and
maintenance of existing state cars
for in-state travel for our Municipal
and property division audit and
collections activities our current Fleet
of State cars is aging
um some of our vehicles
um are older than 2014. so we're
starting to see them come to the end of
their life and not be as reliable so the
equipment money is to start to replace
some of those cars in the in-state
travel money is for the maintenance of
those aging cars
you'll see an increase in employee
training and out-of-state travel and
that is for additional staff to attend
Federation of tax administrators
conferences
[Music]
um well maybe that doesn't sound like
the most exciting conference
um I can tell you that they are very
beneficial they provide great training
opportunities for our staff
and so we would like to continue to
attend those
moving on to page six in terms of
additional requests and I guess these
are really just differences between what
the agency requested and what the
governor funded
in class 27 transfers to doit we had
requested funding for two positions that
are currently unfunded and they remain
unfunded in the governor's budget and
those are in order to prepare for the
fact that 40 to 60 percent of our doit
embedded positions at dra are eligible
for retirement in the next biennium
so I would like to get those positions
funded so that I can bring new employees
in and start the knowledge transfer
process that will also help us
um set the groundwork for taking on more
and more of that responsibility for the
maintenance of the rims system so in 24
the salary and benefits for those two
positions is a hundred and forty one
thousand six hundred and twenty seven
dollars and in 25 those two positions
salary and benefits is 148
417 dollars
also a difference between what the
agency requested and the governor funded
we had requested
um additional rims Consultants we had
actually asked for eight
um Consultants the governor funded six
in 24 and 5 in 25. we are currently at
10 so this will start to Trail us off
and get us to a place where our Reliance
on the Consultants is less and that we
take on more of the work internally as
we were just discussing I'd like to see
that be a fairly smooth transition so if
we were to fund the eight that we had
originally requested it would be an
additional 864 024 and 1.3 million in
25.
lastly just the last change between the
agency's request and the governor's
funding is in the equipment line again
to replace some of our aging State cars
we asked for would ask for an additional
150 000 each year the cars are running
somewhere between Thirty and forty
thousand dollars a piece and so as our
Fleet ages we will start to need to
replace those
can we just back up to 27 again yeah
that uh 864
000 is for how many additional that
would be two additional
again on a time and materials basis so
if I were to contract for those two
that's what I would pay but we have an
existing time in materials contract and
I intend to continue with the time in
materials contract so that if I don't
use the services or don't feel the need
for them I'm not going to pay for them
so it would just be for the work
performed I guess I'm just having it
very difficult time getting my head
around two individuals
Consultants 864 thousand dollars
they're expensive and I will tell you
that these are even based on hourly
rates that we locked in in our original
contract back in 2018. So if I were to
go back out and request current rates
they would be even higher so I know that
it's expensive I am very much aware of
it I do want to transition to doit
supporting
um this application it's just not
something that can really happen
overnight so again trying to make that
smooth effective transition
um
we will be sufficient with what the
governor has funded with six and five I
just wanted to be transparent if you
were to look at the difference between
what the agency requested and what the
governor funded and that's the
difference representative McGuire thank
you Mr chairman so with the the first
item the the two new
um doit people
are they working in that same area so
they would so having them would would
let us use fewer Consultants faster
maybe correct because could we take over
kind of correct that is part of the plan
so get these two new people on board
have them learn from the existing doit
employees and learn from the fast
Consultants one thing that I will
mention is we talked about this during
the meet and greet the don t employees
that are with us at dra started on a
Cobalt system they were working on an
aging Cobalt system four years ago they
have now transferred
um to
the new Rim system which I'm not a very
technical person but I understand that
it uses the vb.net language so they've
you know transferred from Cobalt to
vb.net we have received um arpa funds to
upgrade the rim software to use c-sharp
language which I understand is much more
popular with the folks coming out of
school and entering the workforce these
days so my goal would get would be for
these two positions that you reference
to hire those people that are interested
in c-sharp in order to help that
transition so the upgrade to the rim
system with the arpa funds to move to
c-sharp is part of the big master plan
of getting us to a point where we can
more sufficiently support our system
any further questions at this point
yes representative evil followed by
camera so what are the materials exactly
in these times and time and materials I
use that term loosely it would probably
be any Associated travel
um if
in a more
um in a different time and materials
contract if I was paying Consultants the
materials be the travel costs to come
and visit the dra and do the work here
fortunately in these cases as I
mentioned previously all of these
Consultants move here
um so the materials are relatively small
it's basically just the cost of of the
hourly rate of the employee that we
would be using
so are you Contracting for like a year
of service or when you consult with them
you sort of if you need them for a week
they come in and then they go away or
how does that for the most part up until
this point they have we have what we
call fasties on site at all times
because our needs have been fairly
significant because we're you know just
within the first year or so post
implementation
um
so we haven't had kind of the need for a
one-off person for a week or something
like that it has typically been you know
generally needing the resource for a
prescribed period of time
but we make sure in that contract we
have the flexibility to say okay we
don't need six resources anymore we're
ready to go to five and we just need to
provide them with enough notice of that
change are they employees of the company
that you okay they are yes
representative
foreign
okay
all right yours again okay
we can move on to page seven if we're
ready
and so I'm just going in the order here
um of the accounting units as you see
them in the governor's recommended
budget so on page 153 you will see
workers compensation
um you will see a difference between the
fiscal year 2022 and fiscal 23 adjusted
authorized and then what the governor is
funding for 24 and 25 because we have
had some workers compensation expenses
um in 22 that were not budget budgeted
for previously
unemployment compensation remains flat
over the the two years and that's on
page 154.
moving to page 155 taxpayer services so
this is our largest apartment largest
division within the department this
these are the folks that staff our call
center process all of the mail process
all of the money perform all of their
routine account maintenance
there is an increase
in class 20 current expenses between 23
to 24 and 25 and that's due to an
increase in our number of mailings and
then the increase that we've seen in
postage
and then there is an increase in fiscal
24 in the equipment line for the
purchase of a new mail opening machine
we do not open our mail by hand we have
a machine that assists us with that and
it is aging out and needs to be replaced
so that's the change that you'll see in
fiscal year 24 for equipment
under
um sir McGuire thank you so I'm
surprised I guess that the number of
employees in this area is not declining
because I would assume that there's a
lot more online stuff compared to mail
and therefore you wouldn't need as many
people
um are some unfunded positions in here
which we are not asking to refund
um refund that's not asking to fund
again in the future
um and
um what we have seen
and we anticipated this when we
implemented our our Rim system and as we
started to see
um filings move to electronic and away
from paper we still get a fair amount of
paper but we created
um different we modified our job
classification and created a
classification series that allows
employees to have a nice career path
within the division but also accounted
for the fact that yes you're not going
to open mail and key information as much
as you did five or ten years ago and so
we modified the job descriptions so that
those employees now perform additional
functions within the rim system because
that's the way that the direction that
our our taxpayers are moving
yeah but the overall total needed
is not really changing or is or is this
area pulling in functions from some
other areas that they are taking on
additional functions and under the class
103 additional requests or differences
between the governor's budget and what
the agency requested we historically
relied very heavily on temporary
services during our Peak filing periods
so we would have temporary employees
come in help open the mail and key their
returns and our own employees would do
some of the more Advanced Maintenance
work we now rely a lot less on the
temporary employees because we're not
having that influx of paper
so there was twenty thousand dollars
that was requested in each year by the
agency that was not funded by the
governor for those temporary employees
moving on to page nine with the audit
division which can be found on page 156.
um the really only significant change
between 23 and 24 and 25 for this
accounting unit is out of state travel
as we increase or get back to normal
with our on-site audits obviously this
is an area that decreased significantly
during the pandemic as many businesses
closed people couldn't travel we are now
reinstating a lot of those in-person
audits so that's the difference there
and then
um this is an area where we had funded
two multi-state tax Auditors in our
agency budget the governor did not fund
those positions
um these are Revenue producing positions
they would each produce about one and a
half million dollars of Revenue over the
biennium so three million in total and I
have you know detailed the salary
benefits employee training and out of
state travel costs that would be
Associated if those positions were to be
funded
didn't we fund a couple of positions two
years ago for out of state
you did additional positions were
created we actually added positions and
then they ended up being unfunded so
those two new positions from two budgets
ago have actually never been funded they
were created and then immediately
unfunded
I thought we funded them with the Senate
take them out I believe so
so there are two positions
um that have that are unfunded
um and so this would be the cost if we
wanted to fund those
represent Maguire so does this mean if
we have these two positions we can add
three million to what ways of means told
us that is how we've done it in the past
yep when once they're funded it will go
on the Surplus statement as an
additional
um three million typically in the second
year of the biennium because it takes
the learning curve
so how many employees are in this area
and and is this do they actually show
1.5 million each so at least at least so
we currently have one two three four
five
nine positions in that unit we have
three vacancies plus the two unfunded
um they are vacant at the moment because
this is a very difficult time of year
for us to hire for those positions as we
get into tax season
um we'd like to be a little bit
strategic and post these positions for
higher
um shortly after April 15th hoping to
potentially entice those folks that have
had a rough tax filing system and
Private Industry to come and join us
um in state government
so
we will be actively recruiting for those
once we get through our busy season so
you think in the summer you may that's
the whole pick those up yeah thank you
any further questions at this point
pay attention
on page 10 we have the collections
division which corresponds to page 157
of the governor's recommended budget
changes here you'll see a change in the
overtime line and that is an increase
due to Peak periods of collection
activity where work occurs outside of
normal work hours the primary driver of
this is fair season in the fall we have
uh folks of in our collections division
go out to the fairs meet with the m r
operators who are there make sure that
they are licensed collect any
outstanding amounts that may be due in
that time obviously those fares tend to
occur on the weekends so we request
overtime for that
um land acquisition and easement the
change there is due to fees for online
lean recording services this has been a
great benefit to us in order to be able
to file these liens electronically so
there's just the difference in the fee
for that
and then employee training increase due
to newer staff needing additional
collections training so we have been
very successful with recruiting within
our Collection Division and so we have
some new employees that have come on as
a result of some retirements and so we'd
like to provide them with the necessary
training
to follow up representative McGuire on
your question from our meet and greet
you had asked about how much of our
Revenue goes into collections and the
additional collection or Advanced
enforcement activity so less than three
percent of all revenue is transferred to
collections for enforcement and then of
that less than half approximately 45
percent
um we will place liens or take some sort
of advanced activity
the some of the most busy time for our
collections division is actually coming
up in the next few months
um m r taxpayers our meals and rentals
operators
their licenses automatically renew in
odd years so we are coming up on a
license renewal in order to be
automatically renewed they have to be in
compliance
so right now what we're doing is looking
at those m r operators who are due to be
renewed in June and looking at those
that have outstanding balances and
that's approximately 15 of our m r
operators so what we will do now is work
with them between now and June 30 to
come into compliance so that they can
get their automatic renewal
um and we'll do that through going out
in the field like literally visiting
their businesses bringing them in for
pre-hearing conferences making sure
everything is
um is ready to go for June 30 of those
less than one percent actually result in
US proceeding with a hearing in order to
revoke their license because they're not
in compliance
representative Sweeney please thank you
thank you for being here and taking our
questions on the the overtime Seasons
with the fairs yeah is it one m r
operator per fair or do you have to go
to Every truck we spend a lot of time
going to each and every truck we get
lists of the the trucks and the vendors
from the fair organizers so we know
who's there we know whether or not
they're licensed in advance so if we
have an operator that we don't believe
is licensed we'll know and we will
um go and meet with them and have all
the paperwork ready so that we can get
them licensed hopefully on the spot
um
so we kind of go with a plan but we will
go and visit all of the fried dough all
of the bloom and onions
um lemonade lemonade stands yes thank
you yep
and here I thought taco trucks were
exempt from paying right
we like to make sure that they're all
licensed so they're all on an equal
playing field
um and so that no one vendor is
benefiting from a lower price because
they're not collecting and remitting the
tax
any other questions on collections
okay
page 11 our Municipal and property
division
um just really two changes there one is
in class 38 technology software we have
a technology software maintenance
maintenance contract for our tax rate
setting portal and Equalization
application and so the change from 23 to
24 and 25 is just a change in the in the
contract price for that
and then class 66 and class 70 and 80
employee training and then in-state and
out of state travel and this is just a
change due to again wanting to resume
attendance at conferences and trainings
for our employees to benefit from that
this is the other position that is
currently unfunded that I wanted to
mention so we had requested funding for
a municipal accounts auditor the
position is currently unfunded and it
remains unfunded in the governor's
budget I've included the salary and
benefits if the position were to be
funded we similar to the conversation we
were having about our doit embedded
staff we have a lot of folks in this
division that are approaching retirement
um and we would like to fund this
position so that we can fill it and
conduct some knowledge transfer in
advance of the pending retirements
representative McGuire thank you are
there vacant auditor positions there are
not they are all filled at this time
thank you
so as a follow-up to representative
McGuire's question uh funded but vacant
positions did you tell us how many you
had over the agency
funded but vacant we have 26 we have 16
percent vacancy rate 26 thanks
and the nice thing about the nice thing
about that Municipal accounts auditor
position that we're requesting funding
is those positions actually live within
two different bureaus
um in the municipal Bureau that focuses
on assisting the municipalities with
budgeting and finance and setting up the
tax rates and then also within our
Equalization Bureau which equalizes
every year all of the properties within
the state so that auto that position
lives within both of those bureaus and
so by filling it we would be able to
kind of cross-train in multiple areas
oh with all those funded but vacant
positions how can we make it work that
you could get some of those positions
like the out-of-state Auditors and
and roll that in because obviously
you're functioning fairly well from at
least that's what would appear so how
can we make it work with all the funding
you're getting for those unfunded
positions
so
alternatively what we can do is proceed
with reclassifying the the positions
that are vacant
um that process has been on hold until
recently as the division of personnel
um moves through the reclassification
design process and we transfer to a new
classification system that's been in the
work for works for a number of years it
seems like we're in the final stages but
the reclassifications have kind of been
on on pause while we transition to this
new system so once the the
um we're able to efficiently reclassify
positions we can effectively do that
take some of our vacancies and create
them it's just a lengthy process to do
so
I've heard this problem before but I'll
let representative cambrell's speak to
this question perhaps go ahead well
thank you Mr chair kind of to follow up
on what you're saying um I noticed that
so you have 26 vacancies but yet I found
very little overtime throughout
throughout the Departments so is it an
assumption that some other people are
doing some of the work that for the
other and you're not having to do the
overtime correct correct we we try to
um really limit overtime to when we know
we're going to need it like Fair season
for collections or within our taxpayer
services division during Peak filing
season like March and April otherwise we
encourage employees
to accumulate comp time we allow them to
accumulate up to a week at a time and
then utilize that comp time in order to
kind of prevent I'm trying to prevent
burnout type situations and also be
mindful of our budget over time can get
expensive
um so trying to utilize both in a
balanced way
I know you may not be the one to answer
this question but why is it taking so
long for the reclassification
um
I will just say generally it is very
complicated we have you know hundreds of
classifications
[Music]
um within the state at the moment and
we're trying to I think rightfully so
move to
a more defined classification system
that's actually used by the federal
government and kind of managed by the
federal government
um and but it literally takes looking at
every employee and moving them into the
new classification in the new system is
that committee and part of Das yes
that's been headed by the division of
personnel at Das
um
like I said I do believe we're in kind
of the final stages of getting that off
the ground I think the hope is by July
1.
um all agency heads are part of a
stakeholder group at this point where we
meet once a month to make sure that
everything is moving and the impacts to
our agency are exactly what we
anticipate
um so it is moving along I think it's
just the complexity of ten thousand
state employees and hundreds of
classifications I guess which is here
said that scared me was that we're
trying to model this after the federal
program I think it's it's more
um
it's a and then unfortunately I
apologize the name is escaping me um but
Lori rudis uh the director of the
division of personnel it's a
classification system I would say it's
not the federal classification system
but it's a classification system that's
kind of maintained
um at the federal level so that we don't
have to the state doesn't have to do as
much ongoing maintenance of our
classifications in the future it's a a
more common classification system is
probably a better way of saying it as
opposed to the classification system
right now
um exists solely within the state of New
Hampshire we're trying to move to a more
common classification system
um that therefore doesn't require as
much fine-tuning for our own needs
together
okay
everyone's favorite page 12 flood
control
so the fiscal year 24 and 25 budget so
oh I'm sorry I'll back up for a second
um this is a split between agency income
and general fund income the agency
income is the amount of money that we
the dra slash the state of New Hampshire
receives from
um the Commonwealth of Massachusetts and
the state of Connecticut for their share
of the Merrimack River Valley Compact
and the Connecticut River Valley compact
the general fund money is the state of
New Hampshire's portion so again the
purpose of this is to reimburse towns
for land that was is essentially no
longer taxable
as a result of flood control that's been
done on the Merrimack River Valley in
the Connecticut River Valley so
um there is land that municipalities
used to receive Revenue taxes from that
they no longer do because we are trying
to control the flooding of these Rivers
expanded the rivers tax land is now
under the river
so the states of Massachusetts
Connecticut and New Hampshire reimbursed
the municipalities for that
the fiscal 24 and 25 budget amounts
assumes that Massachusetts will
reimburse their share of the 70 of the
Merrimack River Valley compact as well
as 50 percent of the Connecticut River
Valley Compact and the state of
Connecticut will reimburse their share
of 40 percent of the Connecticut River
Valley compact
as you may know there is a long history
of Massachusetts not paying its
obligation timely or sufficiently for
the Merrimack River Valley compact
although I am happy to report
outstanding amounts for fiscal years
2015 through 2022 were recently settled
and we received a payment of almost 3.5
million dollars by the state of
Connecticut
I'm sorry the Commonwealth of
Massachusetts
the governor is authorized to draw a
warrant for the payment of
reimbursements out of the money in the
treasury that's not otherwise
appropriated so when they don't pay the
governor draws a warrant
so the towns are always made whole it's
really just the
disagreement between the state of New
Hampshire and the state of Massachusetts
so we are all caught up through fiscal
year 2022 we have not yet received
payment for fiscal year 2023 that was
not part of the settlement 2023 is not
over yet we may still receive payment if
we don't we will request the governor to
draw warrant to pay the towns
representative evil
um is there a basis upon which they're
not paying or are they just not paying
do they have any argument
I was not part of the settlement
discussions that was um
managed through the Attorney General's
office
um
I don't so I can't really answer that
question
they must just be being obstreperous
represent Maguire thank you do any of
these funds are they used for building
or maintaining dams or other flood
control structures nope there's they go
right back to the municipalities to
reimburse them for the the land taxes
that were lost essentially by
um by the river expanding I see because
I might argue they're not providing
services to people who are not living in
those places and therefore their
expenses are less right so anyway all
right thank you it's been a long debate
this division yes I think what 12 towns
or something that I know my town is one
of them but Hopkinton and Henniker
um
yeah where has got a big chunk
when the river yep and this is not the
first settlement that we've entered into
with the state of Massachusetts the the
pattern has been that there um is a
period of time for which payments are
not made we negotiate a settlement we
receive payment then we go through a
period of time
um so the last settlement prior to the
current one was in 2014 and then you'll
see that the most recent settlement
starts in 2015 through 2022. it's it's
very interesting because they're a
commissioner's set up I think Jerry
knows this well but just different
Commissioners from different states but
you can have a deadlock and nothing gets
done the way they set it up as far as
members but it's been an ongoing problem
since the 50s yeah so but they're like
national parks in a sense because
they're owned by the federal government
uh yes represent Griffin
um did we get the full amount or is this
some kind of a
I believe that was the full amount or
very close to
within 30 cents I don't know about that
I see it yes it was
30 30 cents
um if there's one thing that we are we
are accurate
um
so I I believe that is very close to if
not
um the full amount that was outstanding
um without interest for the period of
time representative Sweeney thank you Mr
chair so how do we evaluate or value the
land that's underwater do we take what
it was before it was flooded and then
just do a formula to today's projected
value or we do that at the dra I believe
looking at the equalized value knowing
how much land in that town was subject
to
um the flooding of the river and looking
at the current value what we believe to
be the current value of the land so we
do that calculation every year on a
yearly basis thank you
okay
page 13 just a couple of small
accounting units land taxes lost on page
60. this is the state and federal
forests
um so the amount of money that
um is paid to reimburse those
municipalities and this reflects the
current acreage values and tax rates and
then we have the current use board and
the assessing Standards Board these are
both administratively attached boards to
the dra and the amounts reflect the per
diem rates in in-state travel
reimbursement for folks that attend
those meetings
on page 14 we have the low and moderate
hardship grants so this is the money at
the beginning that was coming from the
education trust fund
you will see if you look at fiscal 23
adjusted authorized of 800 000 and then
the governor's budget for 24 and 25 at
one and a half million in each year that
is a result of chapter 95 the laws of
2021 that increased the income
limitations and the maximum amount of
tax relief available for the program
so that change was effective for the
April 1st 2021 property tax year and we
had
5918 claims issued totaling 1.4 million
compared to
5572 claims totaling 800 000 for the
prior year so that increases just
strictly a result of that change in the
law
um we are fine for 23 even though we are
going to over spend that appropriation
because again the governor can draw a
warrant to satisfy the state's
obligation there
represent Griffin please
sure representative Sweeney or thank you
Mr chair so on the uh hardship grants
there were
330 more claims and it totaled 700 000
because the amount per claim also
increased so more people became eligible
and then the amount that they received
increased as well all right thank you
president Griffin you know I'd like to
go back to page nine if I should
it seems to me
that if adding
two two new auditors
brings in three million dollars which is
fair and excess of a cost
uh it seems to me that it would be a
logical thing to do but I'd like to know
at what point does diminishing returns
if I if I added four Auditors would I
get six million if I added eight would I
get 12 million that's a great question I
don't know the exact you know Tipping
Point
um but you know these are our
multi-state tax Auditors they are audit
large multinational businesses you know
think Fortune 500 type large businesses
so yes at a point we might
start to not see as many of those large
returns from those large businesses
because they're looking at kind of a
defined population
we would also run into the issue I'm not
sure that I can train you know we would
be able to sufficiently train you know
10 new Auditors so I'm comfortable with
the two that we're requesting if you're
like let's make it five I might say I
don't know that I can you know actively
um train and bring on those many
Auditors and still generate this type of
return because what happens is at least
in the first year they buddy up and they
go and train with an existing auditor so
they'll travel
to an audit location with one of our
more experienced Auditors and so there's
there's a training need that occurs so
yes there is there is a point of
diminishing returns and it's something
more than two and
less than 15 I don't know thank you
represent uh Maguire thank you Mr
chairman so um I'm inclined with
representative Griffin to add these two
positions as well as the municipal
auditor but to satisfy representative
cambrose could you maybe identify three
vacant positions that we could eliminate
and without too much trouble because
they're already big sure thank you yeah
because right now
um we have six unfunded positions here
we're asking to fund three I would be
comfortable most likely but I will
confirm uh most likely just strictly
unfunding or eliminating the remaining
three that that are unfunded but we will
confirm that for you thank you
so no more questions apparently on your
budget but how about House Bill too
there are a number of items I noticed
there sure so actually one last point
before we move on to House Bill 2 I
meant to mention this when we were
talking about
rims the revenue information management
system I believe when the treasurer
State Treasurer was here in front of you
she mentioned potentially moving the
debt service related to rims into dra's
budget
um that idea
um is something that we would not be in
favor of I've also spoken with the
governor's office and the department of
administrative services and
none of us are in favor of doing that
the reason is because although
the rims Debt Service will be funded by
Revenue uplift we talked about this
during our meet and greet meeting
the 30 million one hundred and sixty
thousand dollar Capital appropriation
six million dollars of that is funded
principal and interest is funded by the
general fund the remaining 24 million
one hundred and sixty thousand dollars
of principal and interest will be funded
by Revenue uplift that the system
generates and the dra transfers up to
four million dollars a year into this
rims Revenue uplift fund that will fund
that debt service
however I can't guarantee and this is
what the department of administrative
Services said as well
our duty under the statute is to
transfer up to four million dollars
I can't guarantee that we will transfer
four million dollars every year we did
this year
um but there is a risk that that rims
Revenue uplift account would not have
the sufficient funding to pay the
principal and interest therefore the
general fund would pay it and the rims
Revenue uplift account would pay the
general fund back when there were
sufficient funds so in that sense this
is not a self-funded
we're not a self-funded agency this is
not a self-funded Debt Service
um it has a dedicated fund associated
with it but it's not exactly self-funded
so we would not be in favor of um moving
The Debt Service from treasury's budget
into dra's budget so I just wanted to
touch on that because I know that was a
question that came up previously
so since you're mainly General funded
and lacking 26 funded positions do you
have any idea what you'll be returning
to the general fund at the
at the end of the year
I don't have that number
um in front of me
um
our budget outside of salary and
benefits is very tight for us this year
you know even though we are 75 percent
people with salary and benefits when
there are excess in those accounts we
can't use that money to fund other
things you know so I can't take a vacant
position and go buy a state car that I
desperately need
um so we're feeling pretty tight this
year because of that because most of our
excess is in salary and benefits and I
don't have the same flexibility with
that money
um
if that kind of answers your question
I know you let don't like the use the
word refunds yeah
so anyway are there any more questions
at least on the budget portion and if
not we'll move to House Bill too I'm
sure
we have the first one around 103 section
10 section 101 101 to 109. oh yeah a
little Communications tax repeal
communication Services tax repeal
so section 101 page 36 those of you look
correct
repeals the communication Services tax
effective July 1.
Section 102 still on page 36 starting on
line 25.
what this does is allows the dra to
still perform audit and collections
activity on this tax this language is
identical or very similar to language
that is currently in statute relative to
the interest in dividends tax so we
still or we would like to still have the
ability to perform collections activity
on outstanding debts to still audit
taxpayers for the years in which the tax
was in place
without this and just the straight
repeal of the tax we don't have the
clear authority to continue to do that
so I I'll have to back up a little bit
back to the repeal 101
did Ways and Means support the repeal
that seven percent or did they leave it
do we I believe they have that's right I
believe they haven't voted on it yet
they haven't voted on it they have a
bill that does exactly that correct okay
so we still don't know we still don't
know correct so just a quick question
yes represent people so the bottom line
is if the if the tax is not repealed
then you don't need the language in 103.
102 correct if the tax is not repealed
there's no need for any of these
sections so
102 through 109 is specifically related
to the uh the repeal so section 101 goes
away we're not going to repeal the tax
we don't need any of the remaining
sections
well that's very helpful for the LBA and
the rest of us so I guess they better
not repeal the taxes
um and that's about what 30 million a
year
so that is between 25 and 30 million a
year it was closer to 40 45 million this
is a tax that's been declining in recent
years
um for a number of reasons
one
um
you know 15 years ago 20 years ago this
tax was primarily on landlines right
now there's fewer landlines
um so for a while though you had a
landline and you had a cell phone so
that was two taxable things now very few
people
have landlines and everybody has a cell
phone
so now we get to the cell phone problem
the cell phone is a combination of
calling and texting which are is taxable
it's two-way communication under the
communication Services tax but it is
also data in its internet access
we cannot tax internet access there's a
federal prohibition against that New
Hampshire was grandfathered in we were
taxing internet access however that has
since been repealed and we can no longer
tax that because we are prohibited
federally
so when you have a cell phone and you
have a cell phone bill
the amount on your bill that's taxable
depends on how your wireless provider
allocates that bill to talk and text
versus data and what we're seeing is
more and more providers because this is
also the trend right more and more
providers are allocating more of your
bill to the data portion more people are
using their phone to access the internet
and not to talk on it
um so that is decreasing the taxable
base of the communication Services tax
so we are seeing it between the 25 and
30 million each year but it had been as
high as 40 and 45 but it's just kind of
a decreasing tax at this point
all right represent required how many
employees are specifically assigned to
this tax and not any others nothing
nobody just one employee he does this as
part of his other work
I would be interested in
you said overall you collect you spend
half a percent to collect everything you
collect yeah but I'd be interested to
see how that breaks down tax by tax do
you do you have that
um
a little bit more granularity right you
know what's the hardest tax to collect
what's the easiest amen I probably don't
have it broken down in that much detail
because it would require
my employees did detail
everything they kind of because there's
lots of employees who do who do multiple
tax types but when we were here for the
meet and greet we talked about the
interest in dividends tax and how
you know we receive
70 million or 70 000 returns for you
know a hundred million dollars we also
receive 70 000 business tax returns for
1.2 billion dollars
um so the the amount of time though that
employees stand spend on the various
taxes tends to track with the amount of
Revenue we receive from that tax which
is why when you talk about the
communication Services tax generating
between 25 and 30 million I've got part
of one employee working on that for the
most part well that's a pretty good
return
yeah
that's better than that
represents Schultz yeah stupid questions
phone defaults to
to call over Wi-Fi then that's an
untaxable call most likely because
that's a likely attributed to internet
access on your on your bill
um and and we do you know when we added
the the providers we asked them for a
breakdown of what they allocate to you
know internet access versus call versus
text on the plans and you know we you
know ask them to substantiate why that
is the correct breakdown so I mean we we
do press them on that but it's just a
basic truth that the majority of of what
you're doing on your phone is not
actually talking to anyone anymore right
a lot more happens over email
and there are no stupid questions here
otherwise we'd all be in trouble
so okay oh sorry that's okay so I assume
this tax is
um common nationally the communications
tax
I believe this is a common tax in most
other states yeah it's not like we're
unusual correct
so going through the remaining sections
if I may in House Bill 2 related to CST
just to kind of
explain what they do
section 103 on page 36 so we
um assist the Department of Safety in
auditing the e911 surcharges and our
authority to do that to work with them
to do that currently resides in the
Communication Service tax statute so if
you repeal the Communication Service tax
statute you would repeal our ability to
assist them so we're basically just
moving that function into 21j which is
the dra's statute so that would just
allow us to keep doing what we're doing
relative to e911 with the Department of
Safety that's really sections
103 104 105 and 106.
do you have a cost of what that costs
your department to
again it's part of one person's time the
same person yeah okay yep so he would
still assist with doing that um and he
ought also audits other tax types so if
he was no longer auditing CSD he would
just move to auditing another tax type
although that's why the provision in 102
is important because we want to make
sure that you know this idea is out on
the street right now right people are
aware that there's the potential repeal
of the tax we want to make sure that no
one stops collecting and remitting the
tax before it is actually repealed so we
will perform audit activity on this tax
even after it's been repealed to make
sure that what was collected and
remitted was correct
um and then sections 107 108 and 109
those just remove references to CST so
if you repeal the tax we'll just remove
the reference so there's really no
impact there it's just making sure the
statutes get cleaned up
so just on the auditing for the CST I'm
getting
um
are there are not that many they're not
that many providers right there aren't
that many people that would have to be
audited I was thinking about your cost
of collection right it is a fairly
defined group
um you know it is you're but it I mean
it's your telephone companies it's your
wireless providers it's your video
conferencing
um to the extent that that it's actual
video conferencing and not just internet
access so it's a decent
um population of taxpayers
um but it is fairly manageable it is a
monthly tax so when that language
um as I mentioned all also exists in the
repeal of the IND statute
that tax is only remitted once a year it
will take us some time after that final
IND tax year is complete in order to
fully audit it will not take us as long
to wrap up CST because it is a monthly
file tax
representative McGuire pointed out to me
it looks like 110 would also fall into
this as well
state of emergency waiver of yeah
because it's using a definition that's
in the section
definition
I believe that is true that is not
language that I assisted with yet so not
my section but yes I believe this is
also relative to the repeal of the tax
correct
that's great sure
yeah and eliminate the three yeah yes
total position count will stay the same
doing my best
I'm doing my best so yes we will get
that information
um to to the LBA those specific position
numbers to fund confirm the amounts and
the three positions to unfund
um or eliminate sorry so our position
count will actually go down we'll go
down to uh 157 positions
okay
thank you very much
quick question we we need to be clear on
whether we're unfunding or eliminating
eliminating because they're already
unfunded yes
so we'll need the position numbers right
yeah
no is that wrong
if they're already unfunded then yeah
all we're gaining is that their total
number of employees doesn't change we're
not really gaining money if you want to
eliminate
so for the first few uh well these guys
are training going out with a different
auditor
there's no gain it's just six pounds
yeah true so what oh so we should only
add one and a half no no well I didn't
mean true
um
um what will
our total number
of
let me see if I say this right so our
our
employees right we'll actually go down
to 153.
because we will eliminate I believe that
the request is to eliminate three
unfunded positions
so that's not gonna you're not gonna I
guess to your point you're not gonna get
a pickup
of a decreased expense because those are
already unfunded yes I'm looking at the
budget so we eliminate three unfunded
positions we don't pick up anything
correct we hire these new people let's
see yeah before they start producing the
three million correct so so we really
should only add one million is that what
you're saying
because we're adding half a million of
expense
so maybe that was what the governor was
thinking when he
when he when he took it out left them
unfunded
but you're still gaining quite a bit no
I don't it's in that game but is that
right should we should we not expect so
the way two years worth of this income
so what we've done in the past is that
when we when the LBA prepares the
Surplus statement relative to these
positions there is zero additional
Revenue
in fiscal 24 and we would put one and a
half million of additional revenue for
each position in 25. so in this case you
would see Zero additional Revenue in 24
and you would see three million and 25.
that will go on the Surplus statement
for the revenues and then the expenses
will just be what the expenses are to
fund those positions so we don't have to
the budget does the work of netting it
out
I guess like this is 30 years of age
right and it's five million games
so do we just clarify to Mike's question
do we still want to proceed with on do
we still want to proceed with producing
the reducing the position count by those
three positions okay
that's fine
thank you for your time today
Mr chair so we should monitor what ways
and means is doing with the bill
so maybe you guys can Melissa
yeah I sent an email I believe last
night on this bill they're hearing they
have the executive session today at 1 15
I believe so we will keep an eye on that
and I'll shoot another email with what
the results are of that executive
session on the bill
not to keep you here any longer um
please state your name for the record
please good morning my name is Doug
Ingersoll I'm the executive director and
Council for the Public Employee Labor
Relations Board I've worked for the
board since uh
2006.
um
before I dive into our limited materials
okay
I feel like having witnessed the dras
presentation I should have been here
first as a warm-up act that was pretty
intense and comprehensive very
impressive
and also your ability to follow and ask
pertinent questions is impressive
there was a
reference to the ongoing
reclassification project headed by Das
and and a mention of the federal
classification standard it's it's called
the 2018
standard occupational classification or
soc for short
and if you Google that you'll you'll get
into it it's not it's not actually the
system that the federal government uses
to classify its own workers it's it's
for purposes of data collection
dissemination and Analysis
obviously commissioner Arlene house is
the expert who can give you
a detailed explanation on why
they're using that to
migrate the current classification
positions into this new system and what
the benefits will be
um
so I for reference I think we're at page
315 and 316 of the budget book
um are as usual and I think
I've done this six or seven times are
I always say that our our proposed
budget
um and our method of operations are
pretty much the same
there are a couple of new things that we
have in here but none of the amounts are
terribly significant and I think it's a
pretty efficient way
to
manage the state collective bargaining
in the public sector in New Hampshire
when you take into account
all the public employers and employees
who are affected or involved by the
process
um
the board itself has been in place since
1976. we have a nine-member board
equally represented by people with
backgrounds in management in labor and
then on the public interest side that's
where the the chairs come in the chairs
since I've been with the board have
typically been practicing attorneys who
have some familiarity with litigation
because we do function as an
administrative tribunal and that kind of
knowledge and experience obviously is
very handy and useful
we have two professional staff myself
included there's also another attorney
and then we have two support staff
and I'm assuming everybody has some
passing familiarity with with what a
public sector collective bargaining
involves but
couple highlights we determined the
bargaining units that operate in the
state and we look at potential
modifications of those bargaining units
to either add or remove positions and
sometimes there's requests to be in
larger bargaining units to remove a
large number of employees and and create
a brand new independent unit they come
the employers throughout the state come
to us in the public sector with the
unions to go through that process
we conduct representation elections
whenever there's an approved new
bargaining unit or if the employees in
an existing unit have decided uh or at
least a percentage have decided that
they would like to discontinue
participation in the process or if they
would like to switch to a different
representative perhaps a rival Union and
so we're the entity in the state that
conducts all those elections so it's
done by a third party it's not the
employer's responsibility it's not the
Union's responsibility
we hold evidentiary hearings
from representative McGuire yeah I need
some Basics here because I'm I'm really
not familiar with your area so what's
the difference between a bargaining unit
and a union so the bargaining unit is
the group of positions in a particular
employer
who are certified to participate in the
collective bargaining process we hold an
election and they choose who is going to
represent them so typically when there's
an interest in forming a bargaining unit
a union will have visited the workplace
discussed the whole process with
employees
and they fill out and file the the
petition they have to submit
confidential cards that are signed by
employees demonstrating that there's an
interest and if we approve the
bargaining unit we then have an election
and there will be two choices on the
ballot one will be the name of the union
and the other will be no representative
so if a majority of the employees who
show up to vote
vote for the union then we will certify
that Union if they vote for no
representative then the process ends and
there will be no collective bargaining
so follow up yeah so like dra who we
just saw is that one bargaining unit all
of their employees or not necessarily
it probably is I would have to look at
the inventory of State units I think
there are approximately 57 different
bargaining units in the state a large
number of those are covered by a master
contract
represented by the state employees
Association
there are I think a total of in addition
to that Master contract which covers
multiple bargaining units I think there
are approximately 13 other state
contracts in place and that will cover
the New Hampshire Troopers Department of
Corrections in various different
departments
so could the let's say the dra employees
decide we'd like to be part of the Das
bargaining unit or or maybe just the
Auditors say we want our own bargaining
unit or something like that I I think
it's unlikely that they would uh look at
another state bargaining unit and say we
would like to merge with that because
effectively they are under the master
contract
um if they were interested in making a
change and we have back in the pre-2010
time period we saw some cases like this
if they decided they didn't want to be
represented by the Sea anymore there's a
process for them to follow to to try to
do that if they decided they wanted to
opt out of collective bargaining
altogether there's a process for them to
do that
um
represents Schultz sorry Mr chair I mean
it's maybe an oversimplification to say
but one is do you want a union or
continue to have a union and the other
is sort of within that Union with whom
do you bargain is it as a large group or
like localities oftentimes have their
own firefighters bargaining unit that's
separate from
or distinct under the state's
firefighters Union
I think that's a maybe I just made it
more complicated
so so so so we're we're
um
sort of obnoxious and always emphasizing
the difference between bargaining units
and unions I think it's more common for
people to just say unions
and they're sometimes referring to the
bargaining unit itself and sometimes
they're referring to either a
professional Union or an independent
group a lot of uh the professional
unions have affiliations with larger
National groups so firefighters for
example but if there's a
firefighter bargaining unit in a
particular town that bargaining unit is
a stand-alone bargaining unit but a lot
of those
are represented by the International
Association of firefighters affiliated
with and it it goes on and on
so when when we have proceedings on
bargaining units or proceedings on
unfair labor practices or some of the
other cases that gets get filed we have
evidential hearings just like a trial
court the difference is that we're
specialized which is sort of the nature
of an administrative tribunal we issue
comprehensive written decisions they're
published on our website
at any word or decision we issue was
published on our web website usually
within two business days
and you can go back and look at
basically every order and decision our
board has made dating back to 1976
through our website
by law we're also responsible for
administration administering a neutral
program which is designed to assist the
parties if they're at a bargaining
impasse this primarily consists of
appointing people with experience and
contract in past mediation or contract
impasse fact-finding
we also provide that list to parties who
are interested in using it to select
agreements arbitrators and we have a
process that the parties go through for
that the statute also allows the parties
on their own to to agree to different
individuals there it's not mandatory
that we assign or appoint somebody
so page four of our handout
and I'm not going through the handout in
in detail I prepared some slides for my
own reference just to try to hit the
highlights
but on that top paragraph you'll see
there's a reference to an average over
the past five years of approximately 102
cases per year being filed and then
there's a listing of the different kinds
of cases
that are in that number and then
immediately below that is a
condensed survey of the number of
bargaining units in the state by
employer type which correlates to the
number of contracts and I've notated in
there how many of those contracts are
what we call current and how many are
expired so on a percentage basis
across all in all public employers
throughout the state who participate in
the process
86 percent of the contracts are current
which I based on my time with the board
is a pretty healthy percentage it's
never fluctuated
much below 70. I don't know if it's ever
been over 90. it's certainly possible
I'm not going to draw attention to any
of the particular employers but as you
go down the list you can
go across the row and see where some of
the differences are and and I can't give
you any explanations
based on the information I currently
have as to maybe why uh contract
negotiation is more successful with
certain types of employers and less
successful with others all of our all
employers are required to file their
contracts with us within 14 days
after their sign doesn't always happen
but we've become pretty efficient at
chasing them down and then they're
published on our website
so there's information there for people
who want to learn about the process and
I think it's information that's also
helpful to public employers and
employees who are engaged in the process
and they want to see what's happening
with other similar bargaining units
around the state
do contracts lengths vary or they always
like three years or something they do
vary
um
yeah
so two or three years is not uncommon
not uncommon but I I my sense is that at
the county level it's a one-year
contract is more common
you will see and I think this may be
more true in education you will see
contracts that are longer than a
three-year duration obviously there's
upsides and downsides
so if you agree to a longer contract you
could win depending on what your
definition is of winning or you could
lose
obviously if unanticipated circumstances
arises there's always the potential to
reopen negotiations
but in terms of uh approving any new
cost items that are negotiated there's
an approval process that happens through
the local legislative body and usually
for example if you're at the municipal
level you have to wait for town meeting
to come around I think in the for school
districts there's more of an opportunity
to petition for a special meeting but
it's an expensive
proposition yeah
so
representative Griffin you know it looks
like about half your increase this year
is in the rents leases other than the
state
line
yes I'm just about to go into the
numbers so I'm happy to start with that
so
uh we are at uh two and a half Beacon
Street where we've been since 2012.
we're in the first year of our third
five-year lease
um the current rent
for year one is a little under forty
thousand dollars and then there was an
upward adjustment for years two through
five
um and it's around
actually I can get you I think I have
the paper but it's close to 48 or 49 000
a year
which I on a square foot basis
pushes us up to around 9 19 a square
foot I think we're 2300 2400 square feet
so there is a jump of approximately ten
thousand dollars a year in in class 22
because of the
lease
I'm sorry where's Beacon Street
so if you just go down North State
Street just before you hit the Rotary on
the heading north on the left it's it's
the site of the Old State Prison we are
actually in the Old State Prison
Workshop from the 1800s so it's always a
fun thing to talk about
um I have a book from the Historical
Society with some interesting
photographs and I always tell people
that in our back parking lot there was a
a hanging in 1873 so but you you know
there was a workshop and they used to
make bed frames and so there's a there's
a snapshot from 1875 of a horse-drawn
cart that is just full of bed frames
being taken down to the
railroad station for shipment and back
then it was that was I think this the
version of hard forced labor you weren't
the inmates were not compensated and
then around 1880 they built the new
facility up the street so all the
surrounding components of the state
prison back in the 1800s I think was
primarily wooden structures and so
that's all gone but our building is a
brick structure
so
representative McGuire followed by
representative so my my understanding is
that the architect who designed this
building you're talking about did such a
good job and brought it in under budget
that he was like a few years later he
was given the contract for the state
house so
yes so the state house was designed by
somebody who had had built a prison but
I I didn't I didn't know that
more history this was also the location
of the immediate past
um rental site for the Democratic party
of New Hampshire
and one of our one of our neighbors who
used to teach at Bishop Brady in Concord
and has been retired for years but she's
lived next to this building for over 50
years she was there when there was a car
dealership occupying the space and if
you
delve around into the building you can
see the internal structures for a ramp
from Beacon Street that allowed them to
take cars up to their Showroom on the
second floor which is where we are so
it's had a lot of different purposes
um I see it now
as because it's in the middle of a
residential area is as a potential for
somebody to do a you know a condo type
project or apartments but
I don't know what the current landlord's
intentions are
um so I had a couple of other specific
comments on what the differences are
um they're itemized on page five of the
handout under notes
one through five
the biggest difference is that this
budget includes funding for legal files
which is software that's been used by
the board of tax and land appeals for
probably at least 15 years and it's
docket management case management data
management
software we have always shied away from
trying to get some kind of docket
software in our budget
just because I at the time it was more
expensive than it would have been a big
ask but the costing for this
um in Year One
is 17
000 and in year two is fourteen thousand
year one is higher because
of uh setting the system up migrating
data Consultants I think were listed by
doit at ten thousand dollars
the actual licenses per year I think are
around six thousand dollars so my
impression is once we get through the
first two years with this system the
going forward cost will be similar to
what those license fees are but
having gone through some demonstrations
with the vendor
um and reviewed the current system with
the board of tax and land appeals
Representatives I can assure you that
it's a long overdue modernization of our
current systems
um will allow us to
manage our dock attract data produce
reports far better than the way we do
now and the current system is sort of
we're in the Twilight Zone between old
filing cabinets and paper folders when I
started I think we had about 30
filing cabinets up at our Manchester
Street location
and we've done a pretty good job
scanning all that material so we do have
PDFs of a lot of historical stuff but
this
the way the system is currently
organized is the way that makes sense to
me
so that's the weak Link in the chain I'm
the only one who truly understands how
it works and there's there's so many
moving parts to it now that sometimes
the question will come up about
something and and I spent I waste a lot
of time trying to figure out why I did
it the way I did and then trying to
explain it and then a lot of times I
recognize that what I had done was
probably not a good idea and so we tweak
it so this would put all of those
systems into the hands of basically
professionals who have been doing this
kind of thing for years
I think it'll add a lot of stability and
efficiency and will improve our customer
service
so it's related to that node two there's
a seven thousand dollar item for Network
equipment I'm not convinced that all of
that is attributable to
um the legal files I mean we we rely on
doit to manage our our Network closet
and periodically
we have to buy a new Switch which I
think the last time we did that was a
two or three thousand dollar expense and
so um
and that's so that's a one-time expense
and then we have also references in
there to PCS and laptops those are again
on schedules recommended by doit Note 3
jumping to class 49 so for the last year
we've been participating in a program
developed by division of personnel the
human resources support unit
I think I think Department of Labor also
participates in it but
it's designed to provide HR Support just
to um smaller agencies and Boards
although I don't consider Department of
Labor to be obviously at our scale that
don't have the in-house staff that have
the expertise because what happens is
anytime you have an HR issue you have to
deal with it might take a staff person a
week
to to figure out what to do and then to
find the people over in division of
personnel to get the job done and nobody
really owns the particular issue that
needs to be addressed so it's a great
program
uh the annual fee for each year is
around four thousand dollars they bill
quarterly
um
and since we've been doing it this year
I feel we have a much better uh
connection whenever we have a need for
assistance from them and they also
contact us as necessary to make sure
we're aware of relevant things
Note 4
um
I included a one-time expense of seven
thousand dollars to replace hearing room
uh tables
and some partitions that I had picked up
at White Farm the partitions were were
badly used and are now pretty much
unstable at the connections and the
hearing room tables are
probably almost as heavy as these a
little more mobile and depending on what
the activity is in the hearing room I
push the tables around
so I did a little research when we were
doing the budget to find out what it
would cost to get tables that maybe
weren't as as bulky and and were more
portable
um and I don't know what's out there now
but that was that's the purpose of this
one-time expense
uh Note 5 is just an overall high level
uh notation of what the increase versus
fiscal year 23 adjusted authorized is so
fiscal year 24
um 21
565 over fiscal year 23 and then 13
000 and fiscal year 25 over fiscal year
23 adjusted authorized
that's all I have
are there any further questions for the
chair
of the board all right representative
McGuire thank you is the legislature
employees are they a bargaining unit no
I think there's a bill pending and I
think a bill has been filed
fairly regularly to allow them to
organize but I don't know what the
status of the current bill is oh so
they're they're on
they're not unionized they don't they're
not their numbers currently they're not
allowed to organize under emergency
thank you and so so the follow-up
question is
should should a similar status be in
your for employees is there some any
kind of we're not right we're not part
of any bargaining unit yeah oh because
it's listed as classified so that's
right well we're there are classified
employees in the state who are not
covered by any bargaining unit so every
oh I see yeah so every bargaining unit
will reference the department that the
employees work in
so there will be a bargaining unit for
doit
um classified employees for Corrections
classified employees and and some of the
bargaining unit descriptions at the
state level are are much more detailed
and specific like the Troopers
and the Troopers Command Staff and yeah
I always just read classified as a
member of the Union but that's not
really right it's it's just more of
hourly and overtime kind of thing versus
I think it just boils down to are you in
the are you a classified or an
unclassified employee and then how the
you know how the state thank you yes
yeah
thank you Mr chair just a quick question
on the uh
on the class 10
uh can you explain the jump to 293 in
fiscal year 2023 and then it goes back
down again to 266. uh under the
recommended in 2024
so
yeah I haven't actually researched that
but uh the here's the current status we
have one position that's vacant as we
had an employee retire about a year and
a half ago uh and we reclassified
a position
um
I mean to make a long story short short
we were classified a position as a legal
secretary for
which is was a jump of like two or three
labor grades
um
so so that would be part of
well of course that I think that
happened during this biennium
um
but I think the funding and we get these
numbers from I mean we don't plug in
these numbers I think the funding for 24
and 25 is based on the vacant position
coming in at the lowest grade and step
but
I don't know if that equates to the
third almost thirty thousand dollar
difference but that's would be part of
it yeah
otherwise there's I mean everything
everybody has just been I mean most of
the people have been in my office
um well
almost 15 years and everybody is at the
top of their pay scale and there's
really no changes for yeah yeah
any further questions I do have one so
on page four it shows the number of
bargaining units that you I guess
oversee is 660.
how many are you like involved in right
now like working through negotiations on
so we actually do not have an active
role in negotiations except when there
are informal
requests for guidance and advice and
even then we can't provide
representation we can just go over basic
concepts and obligations
um
when we get involved in negotiations
it's because an unfair Labor practice
charge has been filed so two
time goes by but around two years ago in
connection with negotiations on the
current sea contract there were a number
of ulps filed by different unions
complaining about the bargaining process
with the state
and we issued a number of
decisions relating to that but that's
how we get involved we don't actually go
out to the workplace and meet with the
people at the table to facilitate the
negotiations it's up to the
bargain the respective bargaining teams
to do that most of them are pretty
experienced and familiar with the
process it doesn't mean they're going to
get a contract done but they understand
the process
I was just curious like how many balls
are in the air with your board right now
like how many people are before you is
with a complaint or
asking for your assistance yeah well we
have an active we have an active docket
we we are getting about 100 cases a year
in okay that's what I was looking yeah
so but those cases I mean they only deal
with negotiations when the underlying
dispute is over whether one side or the
other has has reached their bargaining
obligation
all right well seeing no further
questions does the division okay with
checking this off
all right well thank you very much
appreciate your time
foreign
so we're off until one o'clock the uh as
I mentioned maybe earlier the Department
of Natural and cultural resources their
commissioner is ill so they've asked to
be continued to another day so we'll
work on some
of our bills and other miscellaneous
stuff for that hour after one
and I do have a question for Mr Hoffman
the governor's proposed pay raises for
all state employees right classified
non-classify everybody is there a
breakout of
the amount for classified and
non-classified
would that be a difficult number to get
from Das or someone to
break it out
because if you recall there was some
discussion before a full committee as
far as if there was changes you know it
would be an issue for labor I was just
curious on how we could break that out
perhaps it's a big number 100 million
dollars so I just kind of curious if we
could break that out representative
Schultz
and I to follow up on representative
McGuire's question that connects to this
to some degree
classified and unclassified positions
benefit typically from correct me if I'm
wrong
um Union negotiations and then
implemented contracts because those
raises typically apply to all state
employees to some degree and the
legislative staff benefit from contract
negotiations
and that small
scale in terms of some of the benefits
and definitely pay increases and by the
way the bill that was referenced was
Renny Cushing's built for many years and
now it's my bill so
um it is in admin Services
um I believe uh if has no recommendation
going to the floor
no it goes to legislative administration
because it's just legislative staff and
um
in recent years some legislatures have
unionized their staff so at least it now
has a precedent in other states and the
I believe Congress has also because the
same laws that apply to State
Legislative staff applied to
Congressional staff I believe the U.S
house also is heading in that direction
at least they were I don't know the
status of that
uh you know I should know the answer to
that and I doubt
all right we'll see everybody at 1pm
thank you I'm based on Mike Kane's
suggestion I've asked um LBA for a
slightly improved amendment that would
move those numbers into fiscal year 23
rather than uh 24
just because currently on paper we have
more in 23 than we do in 24. so
and that that's technically a good idea
because it's before the full committee
in a week or so and it's traveling
independent of House Bill too so it
would actually take effect if it goes
over to the senate in its present form
in 2023 I believe oh I see yeah it
wasn't in House Bill too since it was a
house bill by itself a standalone but
but it's 50 million dollars again all in
one shot
um yeah which is I I love the idea but
I'm wondering
that affects the lapse of
of 23 right
but it would yeah it would yeah it would
yeah and and we may need that I mean we
may need that but through the budget
right but this is the but I mean all
these things on the paper are the budget
right so
at my point
out of the revenue of 24 and 25 is what
lapses from 23.
yes so if if you pass a bill it's
effective in 23 to take 50 million and
put it into the pension fund which I
think is a great idea except for the
fact that you reduce the lapse which we
probably need for 24 and 25.
Mr Hoffman do you have the the numbers
the most recent numbers on
I know that the governor proposed
something like 185 million dollars that
would be left in the rainy day fund
if everything that he had as specials
passed
something like that right the I got I
got an email from Mike Kane about this
detail and
um apparently if you took everything on
this paper right yeah there's nothing
left almost all the bills and all the
house bill too
minus what ways of means gave us
we have to cut up only about 130 million
from the whole budget okay so either by
not passing some of the bill stuff or by
taking some of the House Bill 2 stuff
away now we've added a few here and
there type things right so that adds to
that hundred and thirty million in some
sense but we've also added some more
Revenue too so that subtracts right so
um
that that's my understanding is that
what you think well the latest letter
yeah
right
exactly exactly and and that's assuming
you want to leave the rainy day fund
where it is right now at 160 or
something yeah
I think it's a 180 something but
whatever whatever it is if you don't
want to if you want to be neutral as far
as the rainy day fund if you want to add
more to the rainy day fund then you have
to cut more
somewhere else right so
um okay yeah but does that take into the
labs does that take into effect yeah so
that's everything the lapse the uh the
revenue from because the the lapse is in
um HR 17. it has a 2023 Cal column right
so if you take all the bills plus House
Bill one plus House Bill 2 minus
Ways and Means
it's you've got 130 too much right
you've got to find another 130. well
it's representative Griffin's correct
though that we really won't know the
lapse until June
and that's right
you know what they thought they'd be
returning since they have 26 vacant
generally funded positions and she said
she didn't no okay I was close
that that's that's what I fear I fear
that
we've had a number of people come in
here
that had vacant positions two years ago
that they couldn't find anybody
but they filled them in the interim and
mostly in 23 they said
so I I my fear is that Labs would fall
woefully shot
all right
so back yes represents oh
representational I was just going to add
that in general with State hiring there
still is a need for a lot more personnel
in multiple categories of work obviously
some are better than others but um it's
still we were we will still have a
continuing hiring difficulty for many
years to come until a bigger fix comes
so one thing that you may not be aware
of is we build some of that into the
budget right
anticipated lab so we figure maybe five
percent or something of what agencies
are given they won't be able to spend
and so therefore we actually budget five
percent more than what ways of means
tells us we're going to have right so
yeah
so maybe for now I'll leave House Bill
McGuire 50 alone
yeah I mean okay
again we're looking for 130 together
with the other divisions I think so you
know anyway
so next we have uh House Bill 74 that
was uh relative to the employees unused
during time and that was itl five to
three so we made a decision there
then we go down to house bill
212 that was the funding investigation
testing monitoring for pfaffs
so
how much money was that mister was it
just two
where's my other list
212.
yeah two million dollars and 23 yes
thank you
so we have not made a decision on that
are we up for making a decision on the
two million dollars for p fast
that's out of 23.
I don't know that
you should experience
if my memory serves me right too I think
Des appeared to have funding and a
little under control and
they've been deep into it
I'm sorry we supposed to be we've been
recorded for this so yeah okay so my
apology story just I I was just trying
to remember so they have 22 million
dollars give or take in this pfas Loan
Fund and then they had six million
dollars for research which they had
spent and so this 2 million would that 2
million was going to be used in a way
that the 6 million was going to be used
if I remember right and they felt like
the pfas Loan Fund was really for loans
and that they couldn't use that money in
this way I think but the only other
thing I want to say about this bill is
this was also a bill that was changing
the name of the fund and so even if we
remember I asked him even if we didn't
appropriate the money should we still
include some of this language in hb2 and
they said yes yes I totally agree you
just said so for me I was left with you
let them keep the language for them
changing the names of the fund but uh
and they did say that they were going to
use up the rest of the 6 million before
that runs out before it lapses and in
June but
I don't think they need to spend another
2 million for testing if there was
something we needed to cut out of the
budget I think to me this is a low
hanging fruit
all right represents Sweeney thank you
yeah from their testimony on it it did
seem that they were under the impression
the original 22 million was alone but
there wasn't there's nothing that
actually spells it out that they have to
so can we maybe cut the spending from
this and add in a section that clarifies
they can use the existing appropriation
as a response loan however they see fit
to combat the issue I was just going to
say they're coming in at two so we could
ask about but I had this same question
because I mean I didn't go back and look
at the statutory language for the
original right um
Loan Fund creation well in general I
believe that funded was borrowed right
it was so we really don't like to pay
operating expenses with borrowed money
so that's the problem you know we it's
okay to loan it you borrow it you loan
it to somebody else they pay you back
you pay it back you know that's we do
that a fair amount I'd still like to
look at what the language is that
created it because I mean I do think
there's some more work that needs to be
done to nail down the things I was
second looking at the language because
I thought he I thought they were
relatively uncertain about
whether they could use that or not
um Melissa Mr Hoffman any comments
all right well you're doing that
we go to
2 30 that was the agricultural
electronic data processing system
that was 400
000.
it was kind of up in the air I think we
were pretty supportive but I didn't put
a check mark So it seems to me that
should be high on that list okay I'm
sorry which one was that that was house
bill 230. it was four hundred thousand
it was for Agri agriculture yeah it's
when we met with commissioner
it sounded like they had Staffing
problems too so if they had decent
software it would be really helpful
okay
just doing all these cross references
here is we just approve it
yeah
all right Mr Hoffman will
approve that so it's clear the 400 000
for the Department of agriculture's
house bill 230.
you know we did not vote you know in
that so then we have uh somebody needs
to make a motion right
right
oh geez I'm sorry I'm the clerk
no no she volunteered Bill
representative hatch was a clerk before
yeah
[Laughter]
she's way too confident that's why she
was chosen okay Miss Mr Mr chair could
you give me the bill number again the
house bill 230 230 and the motion was
ought to pass and it was made by uh
moved by Hewitt wait a minute is this
lot to pass or is this include in the
budget because I think we've already
decided yeah yeah so how does that work
yeah and included in the budget well so
what do I put here Mr chair
well it was actually a Ford 2024.
if you look at the sheet here so it
wasn't for it's been moved already to uh
2024 it was intended to be for the next
budget cycle so it would be just to
include the four hundred thousand
so maybe we don't need a boat just a
straw well we can just do a show hand
some indication that we're okay with it
I have my sheet already
so it was unanimous so okay straw poll
standing language
did you get all the previous bills
yeah or or we can
well they they're they're very good too
but we have to keep track for ourselves
you know
hold okay and
all right I mean I didn't do a sheet
sorry guys I was asleep so then we have
um yeah
so then we have 234 relative to
renewable energy credits
okay
it has no Financial impact it didn't
really have a physical and I mean there
was a difference of agreement on what
the financial impact was but it didn't
really have money associated with fifth
grade
so that's going to the full committee
without recommendation
I'm going to write a blurb for the itl
side if somebody wants to write a blurb
for the OTP so okay
thank you
yeah no problem itl side
I mean I'll do the OTP side I don't
exactly know what I'm talking about but
I'll make sure that I do well thank you
you can
copy or or use the blurb that
was in the castle of the original just
just go to representative McWilliams
she'll give you plenty of language
okay
so then we go down to house build 250
that was relative to accidental death
benefits for group two members
and the uh it was indeterminable
the financial impact because of course
we don't know how many people maybe we
kill it could be Zeroes
make sure you use your mic
oh
because
do I need to repeat it no okay good
so I'm looking back here 250. so it did
pass on the house floor
260-103
and it was in the committee 15-5
now one thing I thought was strange
about this fiscal note on this bill was
apparently there's roughly 20 19 in this
category right now and the bill says
none of them would get this benefit it
would only be for new people in this in
this category so I I would tend to think
we'd want to do it for everybody in the
category whether they've they're new or
not you know if we're going to do
something but
I don't know if we have a fiscal note
that
would show show you know what that's
worth what they'll cause
so you're saying going back to those
that
lost a loved one
well it's currently 50 and it moves it
to a hundred yeah
right so presumably if the fiscal note
says how much the 50 is you could double
it and right that would be pretty simple
um Melissa it says four million well
this has a sure I just wanted to make a
clarifying point on the fiscal impact
for HB 250 so the indeterminable
increase for fiscal year 24 and 25
that's just Associated costs
um for them to update the pension system
and then the the fiscal impact for the
actual bail hits in fiscal year 26 which
is 320 000 for the state and 1.3 million
subdivisions
but again is it covering those 19 that
exist or is it assuming that we're going
to get one or two more or something you
know see what I mean yes I think what
they did
they did any new
um potential death in the workplace
yeah coverage it wasn't for the preview
assurance
I think that's going forward this is
just going forward can I can I ask a
question about this sure sure
um
it's a hundred percent forever right
a little spouse dies or the child or
minor children
so
if the person weren't killed on the job
right
uh they'd get a hundred percent of their
salary until such time as they retired
and then they'd get whatever retirement
they had earned at that point
and it seems to me excessive
that you would pay the spouse
20 or 30 years beyond that date
uh
the full salary
McGuire well yes and no because normally
they would get their pension then after
they retire
right so they are being paid for the
rest of their life and some okay so yeah
but the pension wouldn't be the full
amount
these are police and fire and if they
work long enough their pension can be
near their their final salary right I
mean not not necessarily
um and then the other aspect is
we're talking about somebody killed in
the line of duty is they're still a
young person right so they they may not
have yet reached the final salary that
they would have had they been working
you know what I mean so they've been
getting raises and they're down here so
you know it's it's it's whatever it is
but well I would argue that you know
when you're alive you're being paid to
do a job you're being paid here because
you died I mean you gave the ultimate
sacrifice you know on the job so I
wouldn't have an issue with this
are you uh represents Sweeney I I'd like
can we get the numbers to for what it
would be to all the current families uh
that are receive the benefit to bring
them up to 100 and that's fair question
because I think just again reading this
I think it's going forward right
backwards for those that are getting 50
percent
so Melissa and another
tasks or reach out to the retirement
system and sure I will just caveat it
real quick that if they have to send it
to the actuary to do this analysis they
won't do it unless it's an approved
Amendment because it is paid for out of
General funds anytime it's sent to the
actuary so oh yeah we had a big debate
about yeah so ask the question is what
do the current they currently receive
right and we'll multiply by two in our
minds okay so that shouldn't need an
accurate representationals or now are
you saying a hundred percent it would
get to a hundred percent of their salary
saying a hundred percent of the pension
no
say that I'm sorry repeat that again it
was based on the last 12 months that
they worked ah thank you
all right well we're making progress
thanks Melissa
and and the other possibility is that
this won't actually come out of the
general fund because if this is put on
the retirement system it may be the
employers who are going to pay for this
via higher employer rates right
it's not the way it's written all right
I think we got a new fiscal note on this
doing it yeah
yeah the most recent one I have is uh
125 but this should have been a more
recent one do we have a new fiscal note
Melissa nope I believe the one
25th 2023 is accurate
okay so it does
um increase pension rates you can see
that on the second page
of the fiscal note
there was a lengthy uh
background and impact from the
retirement system that they gave us the
bills the bill analysis
says that bill increases the amount of
State retirement annuity payable upon
the accidental death of a group called
number one hundred percent of
convertible compensation that was at the
time the member's death right okay I
stand corrected then I was wrong
oh yeah well there's a lot a lot of
stuff here
that's the answer man I've got more
copies going there's a capital
appropriation this was a repeat password
oh the pfas okay
so there's quite a bit leading up to
that point
I was sending Janet asked about next
week or should we just put General yeah
I said just general yeah
9 30. that's it thanks Michael
so we'll see DS anyway we'll get hope
the answers on P fast and well I can I
can
I can open
let's finish this and then I'll tell you
what this says
all right so then 269 we did act on that
was ought to pass seven to two
that was relative to limiting The
Authority of New Hampshire delegates to
policy making conventions
so it could be here
we've removed a hundred dollars yeah
that was that was the clerk is correct
it was an amendment to remove the house
yeah
we made an amendment to remove the
hundred dollars per day did someone
write a blurb for this one uh yes a
representative Sweeney is coming with a
blurb right okay
uh let's see
so then we go to uh two yeah 269
cyanobacteria is that how you say that
Sino yep
mitigation loan we did not do anything
on that
is is
I have a question
is that the same as red tide no
no green it's similar though
completely different
yeah
you didn't do anything no we didn't can
so
um
because this is a capital appropriation
of 25 million dollars
um I we talked about it and I thought
that we should talk to the bonding
committee
um so I asked chairman McConkey to weigh
in
and
um we haven't heard back from him yet
but you'll recall that the treasurer
recommended 120 million dollar cap on
bonding so
yeah representative Sweeney thank you so
the one question I still Linger on this
one
from the testimony it's a naturally
occurring bacteria that is only the
increase
around an area due to a street that's
been built or septic tanks in the ground
by the water so I'm just not clear on
what the it would seem more expensive
than 25 million dollars to mitigate it
if it's existing roads and septic tanks
that would need to be replaced if the
goal is to actually mitigate the
human impact
that led to the increase so I I'm kind
of lost there as to what the 25 million
will actually noticeably do for these
projects
and and it can only be done on
public lands AKA you can't use it for
private
systems and stuff like that that this
this is for the publicly owned roads and
um
I believe they said they they don't use
the money for for private landowners to
fix their septic Wells or anything like
that
um it's a tough one representative
McGuire to me this bill should be a a
true retain in the sense that it's
the funding is so murky
um
and and the need is is sort of
unknown
um that maybe we really ought to study
this over the summer and and come up
with a plan for it
you know possibly
um
uh you know some kind of assessment on
on towns that have lakes that are
affected or something like that you know
what I mean or grant program or
something but it it's just
borrowing this money and spending it as
Des likes I mean it's it's a little too
vague and a little so I would say we
should retain it and really retain it
and and study it and and try to come up
with a
a more a better thought out plan
representative McGuire is moving to
table I mean to retain really retain and
representative evil is seconding that
yeah and like I agree with that I I like
to say again I'm on I'm on my uh
Board of Directors for our pond and I
can tell you that this issue it's it's a
naturally occurring thing even if you
take the human element out of it when
you get warm Summers this type of a
bloom will occur naturally just with
what's out there in nature with no with
no impact from Human so it's something
that needs to be understood better
before you start to spend this kind of
money and you'll also recall the
chairperson stated that as far as what
actions you can take to mitigate like to
neutralize these blooms they aren't
doing any of that either so it's just a
naturally occurring occurring thing and
when it pops up in a leg they just let
it take its course and then it the
eventually the bloom goes away
well part of it is climate change I mean
if it is land use regulations I mean
there's a little so I think it's worth
retaining and understanding
better so the chair wants me to take a
vote
so women moved by
so to be clear if you we retain retain
then it doesn't go into the budget for
now that's right okay
Okay so
okay so representative McGuire yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative cambros yes
uh representative
Schultz yes representative Hewitt yes
clerk votes yes uh and a chair Leachman
yes okay it's unanimous
I still can't I get lost in the ends in
the eyes
okay
we've all been waiting for
now we have
House Bill 300 that's
prohibiting the disposal of certain food
waste
something if my memories
being supported very strongly by our
Clerk
yeah
would you like to just speak to it we
haven't made a decision we've had two
work sessions on it so I
included in the
talk a lot about the situation with
solid waste in the state of New
Hampshire
we have landfills for sure
um and
landfilling is not a great way to use
things that can be used otherwise many
years ago we made a determination that
we shouldn't be putting leaf and yard
waste in our in our landfills food waste
is something that can be used to feed
the hungry it can also be used to
compost it can be put to good use This
only affects uh generators of food waste
of one ton or more we've had not one
single group step forward to oppose this
it was supported by the ENA committee
unanimously it passed on a Voice vote we
had Waste Management here speaking in
favor of it we had the municipal
Association we had the New Hampshire
food banks I mean this is when you talk
about low-hanging fruit this is about as
low hanging fruit as you can have this
was a hundred percent supported by the
solid waste working group it's supported
by the solid waste management plan it's
supported by all these
um we've we recently passed a new Solid
Waste diversion statute where we're
trying to get weight out of weight out
of the landfills that pass unanimously I
mean all the stuff has passed
unanimously out of the house on both
sides the industry supports it waste
management came in and and in fact so
the other discussion that we had was
that if you want to develop so the thing
to keep in mind about this bill is you
only have to do the diversion if there's
a facility available to accept it
within 20 miles so one of the things is
that you want to help support the
development of infrastructure and
and what the waste management
representative said if you can't sort of
guarantee that you have a flow of food
waste they're less inclined to make the
investment to receive it
so
considering the fact that New Hampshire
has done little or nothing over the last
20 years to deal with their Solid Waste
issues
we have to start doing something
okay so we have a motion to retain
well second up Representative no no
problem so the physical note is really
just the 97 025 for the staffer I know
we're hearing from them at two is that
in their budget or that well because
this because this bill was not part of
their scenario
um it's not in their budget but
um
the fact of the matter is that we have
had no planning department in the solid
waste Bureau again for like 20 years and
so municipalities businesses there's
just no planning there has been
insufficient planning support So this
person would work on this program and
also begin to you know they can they can
use it so they really need a third
planning person which was something that
I was going to talk to them about it
anyway if we agree to include I mean if
we can agree to include this uh with the
second I'll just shut up about another
planning person when they come
so representative McGuire is moving that
we uh no I'm going to Second yeah okay
oh you moved it well he I want her to
write I don't want to write any blue
okay I I'm I guess yeah okay oh you're
right this is retained okay but to put
make it clear it's not a retained
retaining to put it in the budget
retained for a house bill too okay all
right we'll just have a show of hands if
that's okay
so Melissa and Mike the the two in the
budget please
okay next
next well but there was there was a
second bill right yeah there is but it's
not in chronological order okay
I mean if you want to talk about that
one now we can
okay 311 was yeah so we have 311 that's
is some of us know it's Buco bucks the
governor included that in his budget the
funding
um we already retained that since so we
don't have to we don't have to do
anything on that then we have the
National Guard recruitment that was 3
30.
uh incentive program that was moved by
representative Weiler past nine to zero
so we're good there so that's 3 30.
that's 3 30. certain amount
oh they're what
thanks representative
that's what we're talking about we
decided to pass it
that was 3 30 that 3 32.
so um 332 that's with uh School building
Aid so we don't need that Mr chair on 3
30 National Guard recruitment incentive
program there is this amount in house
bill one okay but they do want the
policy language
so you have the option of putting this
in House Bill two taking it out of the
budget or taking out of the budget and
letting this pass right to say we put it
in House Bill instead still two yeah
yeah yeah
because apparently the money was already
in house bill one
then for 311 we decided to retain and
put it in the budget
it's our that is already in the
governor's budget
okay so we're just that's a real I mean
we could technically vote to get rid of
that but
we should probably retain it till we see
what happens in the Senate or no well
once it leaves here it's okay so what do
you want me to just I'll just write here
retain okay so it's it's or just you
could put a no it's already in the
governance Budget on 311.
so then we have the
let's see
337 relative to direct in the office of
professional licensure
public meeting that passed nine to zero
let's move by representative choir so
we're good there is that in the
buttons that was odd to pay okay so
that's going on its own yeah and that's
going Merrily on its way which one was
that the 337.
between yeah because they took out money
so there's it's just a bill yeah
and I think that's on a full committee
docket for whenever we meet next week so
you have a few days
uh
we have 347
establishing a superior court land
doctor we didn't take any action on that
apparently it's uh we had two work
sessions we know that came out of
committee we heard from the judicial
branch they're putting
that judge in their budget Mr Hoffman
yeah Mike has I think two amendments for
this bill one to change 21 judges to 22
yeah which apparently they forgot to put
in House Bill too and the other one is
all the tech stuff about this judge is a
land use judge and that will go into
House Bill 2 as well so so we have two
amendments right yeah do you have those
now Mike or
okay but if we want to we can dispense
with this and do a straw poll of uh
yeah that would be appropriate yeah okay
so I'll I'll move or ask a second yeah
to uh whatever you say put
the house bill 347 the particulars into
house bill 2. perfect
I'll show a hands
unanimous
yeah
sure there was conversation that we were
we had during one of the work sessions
about the
caseload of the superior land use and
the housing appeals board yes and I
remember the when the chairman Weiler
was here he talked about ordering a
performance audit of the housing appeals
board how does one how would we do that
does that have to be a piece of
legislation or is that a question
chairman can ask okay there's a special
group a committee the audit performance
audit committee yep and he can make that
request so we could make it directly to
the LBA from the finance or fiscal
commission
so what I'm thinking is would it make
sense as we're putting this in the
budget incorporating that like after the
first year of the superior land use
docket
initiating a performance audit of both
with that
yeah yeah so I I've been thinking about
this a little bit more
um because because another issue was the
fees charged by the bureau on tax of
land appeal hadn't been changed since
1977 or something and and
um so here's what I'm thinking I'm
thinking that just these are small
numbers leave them alone in the budget
for now but I'll put in a bill next year
that would combine the Bureau of tax and
land appeal an overused Department with
the housing appeals board put them under
one roof doing both items because the
housing appeals board is underused right
and but they have similar experience
right so so that that would be a bill to
combine the two Under One Roof
keep it as I don't know the board of tax
and land appeal or whatever it's going
to be called but give it the authority
to do both
um and that hopefully will re will
relieve some of the overwork of one and
the underwork of the other
and and that's kind of my idea so um and
but in the meantime I'll talk to both
boards and do all that stuff you know
but that that's my current plan
I mean it's not a bad plan
well the Superior Court would still be
there as an option as it is now so so
right now
these are boards that do the same thing
as the superior court and you as an as
somebody who wants to appeal uh has a
choice I go Superior Court route or I go
board route right and that won't change
right so
yeah
oh okay
oh that's funny okay
so do you want to speak to you I mean
well I just wondered if since the
housing appeals board is unfortunately I
wasn't here for their presentation so I
may be speaking out of term but for the
housing appeals board since it's so
underutilized could we level fund them
we can do whatever I mean I don't know
what the number was that they requested
or I don't know what you had in mind I
don't think it was an increase right no
I thought it was they had an increase
yeah
I thought it was three people and things
well they had a budgetary increase
so there are 128 in the budget
oh I'm unplugged again
ah
we need a piece of tape yeah
I have a nail in it
I'm sure that'll work I see what you
mean well
not really the the
it's really the same as 23 adjusted
authorites they did under spend in 22.
okay yeah they had what but there's no
there's even a slight decrease from 23 I
adjusted off
wait a minute well they had
when maybe yeah they had 390 for their
actual expenses they're asking for 5 17.
for 24. can I stick my ore into the
water oh absolutely unplug his mic quick
[Laughter]
I'll go right ahead uh that's one of
these things where you have to keep your
eye on the ball uh the bill that's in in
in committee is a bill to create a new
Superior Court judge
and you can put a period at the end of
that and because what happens after that
is entirely within the interior workings
of the superior court because they're
only going to deal with uh land uh
land use docket cases
so whatever you do whatever you if you
want if you want to
change anything about the land use board
uh you're probably going to run across
the idea that there's no no bill pending
that would allow you to do that
nobody has suggested that anything
happened to the land land appeal he was
born and thus it's not a prop of subject
to a legislation will representative
McGuire suggested uh a few minutes ago
that he would put a bill in next year to
look at both the housing appeals for the
board of landed tax appeals it may be
combine the two because they have
similar in a sense it would be a new
bill for next year all right so what
would you do with the current bill
all right so the current bill we're
putting in a house bill we're passing it
yeah we're putting in the house bill too
that's that's the land use judge right
and but okay okay
you know I'm sure you'll get a nice
visit from well to achieve Justice well
they agreed right we we asked him about
it and they said no problem
yeah they would be happy to have it as a
land use judge that they would
specifically handle those land use cases
and if they didn't have a case he might
step in or she might step into another
case but that would that would that
would require what he what uh what the
judge was suggesting was that uh they
would the the state would appoint
another judge in other words oh yeah
that's it yeah all right so there's
you'd have to you'd have to appropriate
the money we have we that was in their
budget okay yeah they already had it in
their budget and there's a place in law
which says they have 21 judges so one of
our amendments crossed out twenty one we
put 22. all right okay just want to make
sure everybody understands what's going
on sure
it's like they
they understand their budget in 22
because somebody was vacant
right so you know that's what's going on
that's everything wrong they may still
be made
laughs
so is there any more discussion on
housing appeals board other than
we're all set I guess
all right
thanks
so it being almost two o'clock
Environmental Services is before us
for their second time
as far as their actual budget will be
the first time I believe but they did
have a presentation a while back on what
they do and this is found on page
671 yeah
budget book
commissioner how are you
fine thank you I hope that all the
members are doing well too
you know we have a lot of questions for
you today a lot that have come up with
some house bills and some
House Bill 2 issues so what we'll let
you go into your budget first and then
we'll go on to the other questions okay
thank you and uh thank you for having us
as always uh so our we passed out a
PowerPoint presentation so I'm going to
talk to the slides uh if you have those
in front of you uh so I'll start with
I just want to do some introductions so
I think most you from the orientation uh
that uh the chair mentioned props may
remember uh so the org chart is on our
second page and I'll I'll start with our
chief operating officer Susan Carlson uh
she'll have a
a large part of what we discussed today
uh given that she orchestrates our
budget
um I'll also point out our assistant
commissioner Mark Sanborn
what if you can see him behind me our
Waste Management director uh Mike wimsat
our Water Division director Randy
Pelletier and our Air Resource division
director Craig Wright so and then we
have some additional staff here beyond
that to hopefully our desire our goal is
to answer any questions you have so we
brought some additional staff so I won't
I won't take up time with our mission
statement but certainly if you have
questions about our functions and
mission statement uh we can talk to that
but since we did do the orientation I'll
suspense of those
so some highlights on the budget uh
it will go into detail clearly is our
24 25 operating budget ask is uh 341
million dollars annually a lot of that
and again we can discuss in detail uh is
uh from federal funding increases so the
infrastructure Bill uh from Congress uh
is is Flowing a lot of money for water
and wastewater infrastructure projects
uh through us and really through again
we'll talk through this but uh it
expands a lot of our programs our state
revolving loan programs for both clean
water uh and drinking water again clean
water is storm water and wastewater uh
despite the name uh in coastal
resiliency uh we have emerging
contaminant uh funds from uh the federal
government we have plus-ups and super
funds are we have new new monies for
lead and copper uh in drinking water uh
piping brownfields and uh and Dam safety
and you'll see again at the end a lot of
this we've
due to the extra funding and other
Associated uh impacts we're also asking
for some additional positions here so we
can talk about that so in the in the
following slides
yeah I we we found that it seems to help
the committee says Sue Carlson has has
broken down by category in the different
slides uh of what we're what we have and
what we're asking for so I so I'll I'll
pass off to her for that portion of the
presentation uh but again we're going to
slide number six of the handout
um starting with slide six
um and slide seven slide six deals with
what our sources of funds are slide
seven deals with what we do with that
money that we have
um starting with slide six
um as you can see
um we have a great deal of federal funds
our budget is broken out and federal
funds between the srf fennel funds and
the reason I break out srf separately
from your other from other federal funds
is because they are their own company in
New Hampshire first
and in the budget they're broken out
separately in here so I did that to make
it easier for you to read
um the srf repayment funds those are the
monies that come back to us via loans
that we use to reloan money out
um they make up 16 the srf funds federal
funds make up 26 percent that's 42
percent of our entire operating budget
our other Federal programs are at 50 mil
50 million dollars which is 15 percent
of our operating budget our fee accounts
account for 27 percent of our operating
budget with approximately 90 million
dollars a year
the groundwater drinking water ground
where I trust
accounts for 12 percent and then our
general funds which is our smallest
portion of our budget is 17 million
account for just five percent of our
entire operating budget
as to use this as slides on numbers
um slide seven
as we note at the top of the slide 74 of
all of our funds are going out the door
in the form of Grants reimbursement
loans and contracts
that only means 26 percent stays within
the state
of that small portion operating expenses
account for four percent that's current
expense equipment
salary benefits account for 20 percent
interagency transfers that's payments to
admin Services doit Attorney General's
office that accounts for 7.9 million or
two percent of our budget
oil fund reimbursements and mtbe
reimbursements are 22 million dollars
that counts for seven percent of our
operating budget overall all grants at
47 million account for 14
loans are a single biggest cost category
at 149 million dollars and for the 24 25
operating budget that's 44 of our entire
budget
and then contracts make up the balance
at 31 million dollars which is
approximately nine percent
now
thank you
um thank you for coming so on the loans
category
um how good is our repayments do we do
we ever forgive loans do we have problem
loans what's going on there
we don't forgive loans but
um under the clean water and drinking
water srf there is a principle
forgiveness
portion of the loans which is built into
the federal law
so we do forgive a portion of the loans
and depending on the type of loan the
principal forgiveness is even given
given up front with the first payment or
given over time
with each payment and I do that based on
the risk assessment of the repair
so I could I think a short answer is
we've we've not had a defaulting on any
of the loans that we've we've granted
if that's the question I think which I
think it is but yeah I I guess of this
150 million that's going out this this
year uh or 2024
would how much would you expect to get
back
um and is there interest involved
you said some Is Forgiven right or
something yeah I cannot tell you how
much of the 149 will be forgiven because
it depends entirely on who is borrowing
the money
okay disadvantaged communities
get a certain percentage of principal
forgiveness if the city of Portsmouth
takes all 149 million we get zero
forgiveness
um but if we have small towns or small
non non-public Water Systems they can
get principal forgiveness of different
amounts we actually are required under
the clean water and drinking water srf
program to forgive a set percentage and
or dollar amount of the entire Federal
grant that we do
and then and that percentages so you're
talking about of the 88.2 million right
certain amount which is the Federal
grant for srf yes right so that's going
to become part of this 150 that goes out
so but a certain percentage of that has
to be a grant effectively or well
technically on the clean water side it
has to be labeled as Prince forgiveness
on the drinking water side we do offer
grants so what is that percent is it 50
10 well this is a
this is an odd biennium because a lot of
this extra grant money and this extra
srf money is coming through the bill
program so for instance the lead and
copper Grant which is under the srf
program is 28 million dollars most of
that's going on in Grants
and we can get into the details when we
get into the pages of the budget but if
it really varies normally
um
it is less than 10 percent of our
federal award goes out in terms of
principal forgiveness
so whatever we love but it varies thank
you asking what interest rate and did
you ask what our current interest rate
is
um just so you know our interest rate is
set every August
and right now for clean water it's two
percent
and for drinking water it's a sliding
scale starting at 2.53 going down
depending on the number of years the LA
the the longer the loan the higher the
rate maxing at 2.53
is that all my statute or is it hey
there's all by Federal Regulation and
it's all posted out on our website okay
thank you
foreign
going to slide eight
um in order to show you as the
commissioner said we have three main
divisions plus the commissioner's office
this slide
um I gave to you to show you exactly
what division has the majority of our
money obviously the commissioner's
office we operate at 8.3 million and
we're just two percent of the entire
department the air division is at 12
million which is four percent of the
department the Water Division which is a
combination of the water srf and all
other programs is at 60 percent of our
department they are the biggest Division
and number of employees and dollars and
then waste management is at 34 and 115
million dollars
what I've done on the next slide is to
give you an analysis of our overall
Department
um by cost category what I am showing
you today is what we have for FY 23
budget
our 24 budget and then our 25 budget and
what is the change in the percent change
from 23 to 24 and 24 to 25.
as you can see from 23 to 24 our overall
budget went up 89 million dollars that's
a 35 increase
most of that as you can see is a an 81
percent increase in our grand line of 21
million dollars our loans went up 48 by
48 and a half million dollars and our
contracts went up 16.4 million dollars
um those areas
um are reflected mainly because of the
um the bill money that the governor's
office allowed us to put in the
operating budget this year for 24.25
recognizing the fact that that money is
going to be coming to this apartment
every year for the next five years
rather than us going and asking fiscal
committee to add all of this money
um just so you know Opera money is not
in here
there's no offer money in here
um
and for 24 to 25 we are basically
flatlining the budget across the two
years
yeah
and as you can see there's an unusual
event happening from 24 to 25. loans go
down by seven million dollars and
contracts go up by 7.7 million
the reasons loans goes down by seven
million dollars is because one of our
loan programs is the pfas Loan program
we have a maximum budget for loans of 50
million dollars we anticipate hitting
that maximum amount in fy25
we expect to be putting out loans this
year and then 24 and we reduce our
budget because we were anticipating hit
our Max in 24 and 25. contracts on the
other hand went up 7.7 million dollars
that is primarily sitting in one
accounting unit which is our super fund
EPA has been able to identify a lot of
additional money
and is going to be passing that money
through to the state to work on current
Superfund sites to do pfas remediation
work
we are jumping as you can see the
contracts jump 16 million dollars and 20
23 to 24 about 6.4 of that is an
increase in super fund contracts and
then that seven million dollars is a
second increase on top of that for even
more contract work in 25 for Superfund
representative
yeah so we have a bill to add uh like 2
million for pfas related things testing
and and some other things but you're
talking in the tens 30 you know 20
million kind of category so is this 2
million maybe not not too entirely
separate things this is super font size
oh okay okay these are just work on
super fun sites
and this is just for additional
remediation work on those Superfund
sites is the problem area in Merrimack a
Superfund Site
no okay so but it might become one or
something is this
we don't know okay we don't know
I've given up guessing
um our next slide on Slide 10.
um gives us the same cost broken down by
sources of funds so that you can see
where our increase in our budget is
um we had a um for a general funds we
had a 1.3 million dollar increase which
is approximately nine percent our srf
funds went up 53 million dollars which
is 150 percent increase all our other
Federal programs went up by nearly 24
million dollars again nearly a 90
increase
um our srf repayment funds went up by
nine million dollars
um our drinking water groundwater trusts
went up by approximately two million
dollars and then all other funds from
all other sources went down slightly by
one percent
um you can see in from 24 to 25 again
the two biggest change areas is federal
funds went up by 5 million again in
large part because that is reflected of
the super fund contract money that is
coming through and all other funds went
down by 6.3 again that's the pfas loan
money that has decreased by seven
million dollars offset by operating
increases in other classes
any questions
division members while we're
kind of a
end of budget
presentation before we go into house
bill two sections any issues
seeing none must be doing a good job
Susan yes we always expect
thank you so so again as the chair
mentioned so next in our presentation
we're going to talk about House Bill 2
positions and then some of our
prioritized needs and our additional
asks just to give you a preview uh so if
looking at slide 11 uh on House Bill 2
uh we tried to call it the things that
were more directly involving us so uh in
order of what you see on the slide is
um
that the first line is referencing some
changes we we've asked to have made uh
within the organization of the
commissioner's office so there's really
no budgetary uh impact to that uh the
second line has to do with our
environmental appeals councils we have
four councils that help with rules as
well as appeals and chair so I'm going
to slow you down a bit because what I do
is have the members of the division
weigh in on your proposed changes so we
can check them off and not have to come
back to them if there's a question you
won't be here to answer that okay
yes represent McGuire so I have that
we've checked off everything except
section 18 from 1 to 19.
so uh
what's that
yeah we we checked off
16 no I'm sorry uh 17 and 19 and
everything else we left open
on my page I have checkoffs at one two
three oh but those are different yeah
I understand so what is 18. 18 was the
doj part of it so I I think that section
had to do with the
rearranging that you're doing with your
various councils so we were going to
have them just talk to us a little bit
about that but 19.
so
so let's go let's go back to 17 that's
everyone okay with 17.
okay so that's good
so uh now 18. 18 we did checks
so starting with 19.
um
sorry we gotta find our pages
yeah so 19. oh there it is
yeah
we did that we did that
so some of these here was some overlap
with like the Department of Justice so
when they were here
helpful is there are several sections
here one applies to waste management
Council one applies to water and one
applies to air why don't you just sort
of describe your overall thought here
sure there are multiple sections so so
the doj part of it maybe I can start
with that so right now the councils are
administratively attached to the to the
agency but they hear appeals of the
agency's permit so one one issue we
would like to we were attempting within
hp2 to accomplish is to provide some
distance uh certainly for the Optics of
it if you will that we're not the people
who are supporting the council's work
for me right now
and the councils are judging whether the
the permits that went under my name or
are okay or not so the Optics in my
opinion are not really
great for the public you know we can say
yes there's a dotted line and we have a
Chinese wall Etc all we want but I think
that's not ideal so we're trying to and
I think the Attorney General meta
mentioned to this yesterday I talked to
him this morning again about it uh
it will have been asked for a technical
correction later on in our presentation
but the desire was to move that
responsibility to the Attorney General's
office to give you a preview we also
want to move a position within the
agency as a technical correction that
currently supports the councils to the
Department of Justice so I guess I it's
not much of a preview I gave you the
whole whole show uh on that end so so
that was kind of the the doj part of
that uh that crossover uh the other
desire was we had been tasked to look at
our whole permitting process from start
through appeals and look for ways to
streamline and so some of that language
as representative evil mentioned that it
goes Council by Council but it's really
the same the intent would be right
currently the Department of Justice uh
will appoint a hearing officer for uh
Council appeals and they look at the
legality of the aspects and then they
they convene the councils uh once they
get a quorum and they they adjudicate
the the appeals uh they're some
efficiencies in our opinion that be
gained by
um
a lot of this is just a legal
interpretation so
what we want to do is is streamline the
process but get the best of both worlds
so the intent in the hp2 is our is
another in front of me but as I remember
it is to allow for the hearing officer
to have more
the ultimate decision making but be
guided by the councils and the other
part of that is because the councils
often have
their volunteers uh understandably uh
getting getting Quorum is sometimes
difficult and we've seen some delays in
getting permitting appeal decisions done
is to reduce the Quorum that's needed to
advise the hearing officers so that all
all said is what the attempt is is to
allow the council still to have input
but to help help move the process along
a little bit quicker so that's the
attempt but the budgetary impacts are
really the Department of Justice would
would take over instead of the dotted
line for us it would be them
administering that
makes a lot of sense
any issues there folks
I would support that we include this in
hb2 so it's 19 to 26 those are the
sections
19 through 26
um anyone have any issues
no but seeing none will check those off
Melissa and Mr Hoffman
so actually starting at 17 and going
down through 26.
so now subsurface fees
right into the wetlands so so going back
last biennium so we have uh multiple
programs under our land resource
management uh Bureau uh and we we merged
uh wetlands and sherlin Shoreland fees
last year into the same account and we
basically were asking to complete that
we also want to add alteration and
training fees into the same account to
give a little bit more flexibility for
the programs to operate absolutely
oh it's just sub Circle oh I'm sorry I I
get the wrong programs aot was last year
we liked subsurface to be added to that
I had the wrong program I apologize
that's why I have Sue sitting next to me
so she can keep me nice man
okay any questions representative evil
um I think we should make the changes
recommended in HB to the 27 to 31 second
let me uh represent Maguire is a
question yeah so um like in section 29
and and others you're adding to the
funds that are non-lapsing the words and
continuously appropriated which you put
significance
um continuously appropriately allows us
to make necessary budget budgetary
changes if needed without having
um to go before either Governor Council
or Facebook committee for the small
changes that we need
it it is
um if you look at the Water Resources
fund as established all the sections
have the continuously appropriated
language in there so we wanted
consistency with all the rest of these
to have that same Authority
is there some dollar amount that where
you would go to the fiscal committee
instead or not
no no in all honesty no
but we um we don't these
these programs we don't run with big
changes it just allows us if there is a
changes that we absolutely have to make
like on rent or utilities or other
things that we can do this
yeah most of our other fee programs have
the standard language okay thank you
further questions
on this
representative evil you okay
so we're all set with 27 to
30 actually
it's 31 so
27 to 31.
everybody's to 30. 30 and then 31 is a
application deadline
that one's all right with me thinking
about everybody else
so I'm just going to back up if I could
Susan to represent a McGuire's question
about the continuously appropriate you
said it's a small amount what do you
mean by small
well my definition of small has grown
considerably released
um generally these are our changes are
are realignments of funds and we're
generally we stay you know
we range anywhere from seven hundred
dollars to maybe twenty twenty five
thousand Max most of the changes we ask
um most of every one of our funds has
this continually appropriated language
in it
um and it just allows us to to fix
things as we need them
um but for the most part I try not to
let people use this unless they
absolutely less programs absolutely need
it
um the if you ask the staff in the
department the program staff I'm a bit
of a penny pincher with them so we only
use this when it's absolutely needed
all right so okay so so we're up to 31
that just had a deadline that's good
yeah
so 32
34.
32 looks like big thoughts yeah
28 man
Mr chair
yes Mr Hoffman this lines up with that
house bill 311
grants yes
in the trailer build we're not in
hospital
yeah so that's Tom bucco boxes
some people call it I'm glad to see
actually put it in so representative
Buco didn't have to fight as he has for
decades
so we're okay with that I believe right
okay
so
.
Water Management protection
if it helps the community I could
describe that real quick so so this is
again uh
we we charge on a application fee for
many of our permits in this case is for
alteration of terrain and this would
clarify right now if somebody comes in
with the amendment so it was unclear
that applicants uh whether they had to
pay additional fees for as if they were
starting from scratch if they had an
amendment which is kind of the the plain
language or the the current statute
Our intention is they would pay an
additional fee based on the additional
impacted land that they are are being
charged for so for so this will actually
save applicants money uh but that was
always our intent anyway so it's really
a clarification
so is that the hundred thousand square
what
yes or Surface disruption and this again
this is only meant to the application
amendment fee is only meant to impact
the amount you're amending your project
by not the whole starting from scratch
the whole project again so all right so
also you're not paying the 500 again
right is that the idea you're adding a
thousand feet so it's another hundred
but not yeah something like that yeah
okay
so representative McGuire is good with
that good everybody else
all right 35.
can you describe it
now you're probably easier for you to
describe yes I guess our reading is good
so this has to do with the Winnipesaukee
River Basin and this goes this language
goes back to 1986 uh and it limits the
barring ability of the municipalities to
support the Winnipesaukee River Basin uh
to three million dollars a year uh
that's historically been overwritten by
Capital budgets anyways I'll say two
points to that one is obviously three
million dollars in 1986 is not three
million dollars today it doesn't buy
nearly as much today and second of all
as a practical matter and Sue can
correct me
it doesn't operate that way in practice
any anymore anyways if it ever did in
that we bond for the state and the
municipalities the 10 uh municipalities
that are involved uh pay for their fees
so this is really not doesn't help this
being in this language being in so we're
being asked for that to be taking out
did you need to correct me in any way no
all right everybody represent McGuire
should there maybe be a new limit
because this sort of says unlimited
borrowing right well the the way it
works when prasaki River Basin as state
agency we come into the house and the
Senate
um capital budget committees with a
capital budget request that gets
approved by the legislature
um and that's our bonding Authority
um to do this what the commissioner was
saying with the 10 communities is what
happens is
we expand the capital money is we go
into repayment because
um and then the 10 communities is part
of their annual assessment will pay
their proportional share of any Debt
Service
and and just so you know we we
um routinely meet with the 10 member
committees they form an advisory Council
or Advisory Board
um and we clear any Capital requests
that we tend to make with them before we
submit anything to the legislature but
you're directed to do that by some other
section of law
or is that just no we do that as a
matter of course
so I mean there is an Advisory board
that we do meet with but we make an
extra effort to make sure that they are
on board before we ever expend a lot of
money on capital projects
so how many users use that state waste
what a treatment plan I know it's a huge
system right
and as far as
bringing that back
okay Mission are you and perhaps Remain
the future
discussion on a future slide too just to
remind the the committee uh obviously
where Kanye Center rate payer money here
but there's no General funds associated
with this this is totally supported by
the member communities
I'm not sure all of us know what this is
It's a wastewater treatment plant that
sure so thank you for that so I I think
we're unique in the nation so the so
there's the Winnipesaukee River Basin
project uh was was a is a wastewater
treatment facility with collection lines
and pumping stations uh there's a
station in uh Laconia uh and and the
main treatment facilities in Franklin
New Hampshire uh and we we basically
treat sewage for those communities in in
those 10 communities in that area
um so I think we're pretty unique
because my understanding is so so that's
owned and operated by the state Des
staff uh run run the facility and as
alluded to uh there's an Advisory Board
of the member communities uh the the
expenses for it for in uh for the the
project or the waste right treatment
facilities are paid for by user fees for
for those 10 communities
and again the intent is you know I I
don't go back that far but Randy
Pelletier does uh that was a slam at him
I guess uh is is you know this was
originally intended to reduce uh water
impacts for Lake Winnipesaukee in that
that whole basin
all right see no further questions on
this we can
check this one oh did you have represent
why
representative McGuire would like to see
a lemon I believe yeah I mean 30 million
or something I mean I don't know
when this paragraph was first written
whoever wrote it thought that the limit
meant something
um
30 million that's fine it's just at this
point none of the communities are and
even this agency understands why the
limit was set at three million dollars
it's it's an Antiquated dollar amount
and we're just trying to
adjust the statute so that I mean are
you bumping against this limit is that
what's going on we are way over
Mr Pelletier if you could grab a
microphone please
yeah
I I think to answer that question uh
representative there's uh pipelines are
bursting in Berlin the 140 Route just to
replace that pipeline six and a half
million dollars
it used to be when I was younger we
could put in a mile of pipeline for
somewhere around 850 to 900 000 today to
put in a mile of pipeline is well over
two million so when you look at
infrastructure improvements for not only
this plant but I Wastewater plants all
over the state the like Portsmouth just
completed their upgrade 87 million
I mean so the when you start to cap an
issue and let's say we had multiple
failures at Winnipesaukee River if we
had to clarifier go down or we had a
major pipeline leak that could easily
get into a 10 million dollar ticket but
I also want to note that because I meet
with the Advisory Board every month and
they do have a 10-year Capital
Improvements plan so anytime a project
comes before to be bonded it's approved
by this 10-member Advisory board so it's
well thought out
good reason there was limit put on it
and I think he suggested what 30 million
yeah yeah at least may call attention
I mean
is that right yeah okay representative
Kimbrell's thank you Mr chair so what is
currently with that language that is in
there now how did that affect you
did it stop you from doing anything um
uh stop the department from
so whether we put 30 million or 100
million it doesn't matter anyway
so I don't know
and to add on to that so again as I
mentioned is this historically is
overridden but this this limit is
overridden by the capital budget so so
you know I won't say you you're a
different committee but but they put
language in the capital budget to say
correct I see I see okay but at least it
has to be overridden by somebody if
there's no limit there it doesn't have
to be overridden by anybody yeah
all right so can I move the the we
change
change section 35 so it keeps the
language but changes three million to 30
million it's been moved is it second is
it's been moved and seconded by uh
representative
Dave Hewitt is there any further
discussion I'm bringing the limit to 30
million seeing none just to show it
hands please
Jenny Adams
just like a few controls
all right so moving beyond 36.
commissionary
X I'm going to let Sue Carlson do this
she'll do a little bit better but really
right now the the law requires a certain
date for issuance date specific of
issuance of quarterly bills again we the
rate payers from those communities pay
for that and we want a little bit more
flexibility than that so we can add to
that yeah what
um the current law says we are supposed
to issue the bills on the July 15th
October 15th January and April 15th
um it is nion impossible for us to issue
bills especially on July 15th
um mainly because we can't even close
the books by July 15th in order to send
the next Bills out so we were just
looking to maintain the quarterly
billing but just remove those action set
dates where was that Maguire no problem
yeah
all right
um
37 new chapter
PCB
so if I could so the the PCB fund that
this would establish so I'll go back in
time a little bit so uh this the funds
that went to the general fund uh stem
from a a settlement that the doj was
able to work with Monsanto uh The
Chemical Corporation for contamination
in different parts of the State uh so
you know right or wrong depending on
your point of view typically the the
Department of Justice would try to
Target a where this money goes uh they
the settlement happened so quickly they
it just went to the general fund which I
think is fine and and the the amount
that went to the general fund was I
think 20 million Mike wimp said it's
gonna either
not his head or shake his head behind me
he's going both wins is this the MTB no
it is PCP so so I started I say that
because if I remember correctly 25
million was was what was was uh that was
was he agreed upon monies and we had the
state had to pay off their their
external attorneys Etc and then the rest
went into the uh general fund so the
intent was always that some of these
funds would go towards some mediation
and other work for pcbs and this is an
attempt to do that so again a majority
of this is still going to the general
fund but we're asking for for this
amount to to go towards some a fund that
we could use towards cleanup and
Associated things with PCB contamination
is PCB still a significant problem in
the state or
uh well let me if if I could I can bring
up Mike website I wouldn't want him to
lose out since you had Randy Pelletier
up if that was
so again Mike's with our Waste
Management division good afternoon yes
and actually um I think Rainey might be
the right person to answer this because
much of these funds are going to be used
for um looking at water quality and
sediments and such that's where we're an
area where we can still make some
progress in PCB assessment and cleanup
um pcbs we to answer the direct question
pcbs were used in so many uh products
they were in addition to what most
people associate them with which is uh
dielectric fluids and Transformers and
such they also went into paints they
went into caulking they went into window
glazing and floor tile cement so they
occur in many many places but this fund
is really not focused on that I believe
it's going to be focused on looking at
monitoring over time and understanding
the impacts of sediment and water
quality issues with pcbs on biota and
such and rainy is welcome to add more if
you need is a question for the director
representative
thank you very much so again two
questions that are kind of in one how do
1929 to 1977 seems like very specific
for in terms of us knowing that it was
dumped into the water
are we confident there hasn't been any
dumping since 77 and what other ways of
studying have we done so far on this I
believe that manufacturing ceased after
that time and so what we're really
looking at is essentially Legacy impacts
that were even though they stopped
manufacturing them they were still
well Statewide thousands probably
nationally millions of Transformers that
contain PCB fluids and that were in
service and then when they would fail or
blow up in some cases as they do those
release so releases certainly occurred
after 1977 but I think the manufacturing
ceased at that time thank you all set
represent Hewitt followed by
representative Schultz
oh okay I'm sorry representations and
isn't this similar to some of the other
quality issues of isn't it more that we
have a better idea by detection that has
improved like isn't this easier to Now
find and detect compared to even a
decade ago or am I
you know because that would make it
similar to
um why am I blanking on the acronym be
fast thank you pfas yeah just say
feedback
very very true you're certainly correct
with respect to pfas I think with pcbs
I'm not specifically familiar with the
advancements that have been made since
you know in the last 10 years on pcbs
but I think we've had a pretty good uh
pretty low detection limits and pretty
good analytic capabilities for pcbs for
quite a bit longer than that
all right thanks uh yes represent
Griffin so as as I'm looking at this and
listening
uh the six million dollars has already
been received
as part of the settlement
so again all the settlement monies went
into the general fund we're asking for
to take some out of the general fund and
section 39 makes us effective
June 30 23.
so it really doesn't affect
the 24-25 budget
well it's in the collapse yeah
yeah go ahead
um before we add a big section like this
could we
informally consult maybe with the
resources committee or whoever would
normally if this was a bill would
normally hear this
yeah have you had any discussions with
the resources environment and
Agriculture and well I think it's it's
resources that's water right right yeah
I'm not aware of any discussions with
them so you know just just to get an
okay
representative evil where are the pcbs
found like in groundwater are they
coming out landfills or is that part of
the idea of this there are a handful of
sites really extreme cases where we had
releases where we do see PCB
concentrations in groundwater but most
of the time we don't typically they are
bound up and associated with soil and
sediments so the big risk that they
represent really uh if we if we put it
all in context around the state the real
area of focus here and the focus of
these funds as I understand it is to
look at sediment quality in our water
bodies because there are a lot of
Wildlife and Fish and such that who's uh
who are impacted by the content of
sediment since and they can be
concentrated in fish as a result of the
you know
organisms that they feed on in a water
body that are interacting with the
sediments so that's really where the
focus of this money is is try to
understand that understand where we have
impaired water bodies that are impaired
as a result of that and try to you know
take steps to address that
thank you Michael Mr Hoffman and Melissa
I'm going to ask representative McGuire
to touch base with the chairman of
resources
on this one
oh I'm sorry representative yes thank
you Mr chair so I would think
um when you're talking sediments the
Merrimack River would be one of the main
things you'd want to study because there
were a lot of factories back in the day
that probably dumped into there or had
releases into there have not studies
been done already since 1977 like when
the Clean Water acts went into effect so
why are we doing more studies now if if
in fact I'm assuming a ton of studies
must have been done in the previous
years I'll preface my remarks by saying
I am not at the esa expert on that body
of data but my understanding is that um
we have uh relatively little data we
probably know in certain reaches of
certain Rivers where we've done a lot of
studies we probably know quite a bit but
we have thousands of water bodies in the
state where we may not have any PCB data
at all for a given water body so I think
the idea of this is over time and this
will be implemented over a number of
years to try to incorporate PCB analysis
and we may be going out to those water
bodies and taking samples and looking at
a number of water sediment parameters
but pcbs isn't one of them and the
analyzes are expensive so this would
provide funding to try to add pcbs as a
to the list of compounds that are that
are tested for when we do those sediment
studies
you raise a good question represent
cambrell's because a whosatonic river
was known for its PCP loading and
there's been some different views
whether it should be just left alone
because once you start digging it brings
it to the surface and there's signs all
down through the adanta eat the fish
because it's so saturated but again
there's a number of different uh views
on what to do with pcbs but represent
evil I think has a question
I was just we were talking about the
bill I don't remember what number it was
uh earlier before you guys came where
you had requested the two or the bill
requested two million dollars for study
in addition House Bill 212 for the study
of pfas remember you had 6 million and
then you were trying to replace that and
you didn't feel like you could use the
pfas fund for anything but loans if
we're really trying to cut or try to do
better with some of the money that we
have could some of this money be used
for the pfas study too is it a similar
kind of a study this piece this PCB
because it sounds like well the the I
guess if if the full settlement for 25
million went into the general funds it
must not have had guard rails on it for
use for pcbs so you're trying to reclaim
it back for its intended use
I think that's all correct
yeah
well it's just a it's just a thought
I mean if it was the choice between not
having the pfest money or or just sort
of setting up kind of a study fund for
pcbs in pfas she's asking about a
hospital 212. yes understood
know you don't want to give up
use between your children exactly it was
just it was just a
all right so we'll get an answer we'll
get an answer from representative
McGuire once he talks to the folks at
resources on 38 which will also affect
39.
all right so we have
section 47 removes nhdes name from
statute
okay so so again this is just clean up
uh the department of energy this was
was
really in the department of energies
bailiwick so it's something that we
don't really have a say over or or feel
we should uh and we're just asking for
our name to be taken out I do believe
this uh there's also a bill and I
apologize I think this is duplicate so I
think it's in the House Bill 2 here and
I think there's a separate Standalone
Bill if I remember right
so House Bill 211 I'm told
all right that sounds pretty simple
we're okay with that in House Bill 211 I
will say the the prime sponsor is the
first is the same person who put the
language in the first place so he's
all right just go into page 12.
so
I kind of went here already but I
mentioned uh in the discussion about the
Department of Justice and our councils
uh that we we are asking for technical
amendments uh so that we can move our
the position uh listed here uh 19491 the
legal aid position from our department
and move it over to Department of
Justice so they can support the councils
from there instead so uh to the extent
that that those elements are
put forth and passed in hospital two
we'd want this to happen also and I
think attorney general formula may have
mentioned this yesterday also
so Michael and Melissa's Amendment for
that position transfer please
yeah
and we're I'm clocking in a time too so
I don't know how much you want to go the
next slides talk about the new positions
uh obviously we can go one by one if you
like but I I uh we do have some uh
prioritized needs I very much want to
talk about but I will say for the the
positions that you see by and large they
you'll note they have to do with
accounting or information technology
systems and much of that has to do with
we mentioned the large amount of new
money we're getting through the federal
government over the next five years uh
to the extent we have to service those
loans meet all the requirements from the
federal government and and meet all the
auditing requirements that's kind of the
gift that keeps on giving those loans
and we need staff to support those uh
similarly we need to you know we are in
the middle of trying to upgrade our our
electronic systems uh and there's 10
rules on both sides of that so that's
the majority of those we do have some
other positions and again I don't know
how you want to how do you want to
attack those
so to speak
so these are all within your budget
these are not an additional ask as you
have on the next page correct correct we
questions representative Sweeney thank
you Mr chairman so just for these
positions on page 13 how many are
General funds and how many are funded by
the grants and the loans that they're
yeah
um there are five general fund positions
um and then the rest are funded a
combination of fee and federal funds
have that
because I knew you were going to ask the
question
um of those of the other remaining
there's one two three four five federal
funds and one two three four that are
funded with fees
thank you
representative McGuire is a question yes
so you have 478 current employees or
positions how many are vacant
right now we have 71 positions that are
vacant which is approximately 14 percent
and the question you're not asking is we
have 50 of those in active recruitment
so whether we add the what is this 15 or
no 14 14.
won't make that much difference
all right thank you
any further questions on
slide 13.
seeing none
I know there's some questions on the
next slide I believe
so if I could it probably I'll just
outline and then the next slide actually
goes into detail on our additional
funding requests from our prioritized
needs so uh you'll see the figures in
the first one are for the Winnipesaukee
River Basin uh and I'll talk to that to
the next slide as detail uh the the and
you'll see the figures for the the next
line down is for two uh one for one of a
better word orphan landfills that need
some servicing so they don't cause an
environmental problem and then uh we
also have have a we'd like to to move a
position to to full time which I'll talk
about in a moment also so we had other
uh prioritized needs but these are the
ones that we really mean if you will
so the the first one going to the next
slide 15 is uh the Winnipesaukee River
Basin project as we mentioned we've
talked to that already a little bit and
again this is uh as we discussed this is
uh
find it out of those communities so
we've had as you may imagine moving
water and waste is very energy intensive
uh requires a lot of chemicals
and certainly periodic and ongoing
upkeep so uh a lot of this increase that
we're asking for is for utility costs
unless you I'm not not that you would
but unless you're living under a rock
everybody's paying for a lot you know
their heat and electricity is a lot more
now uh the plant has the same same
impacts uh and they're again a high
energy user uh the supply chain issues
especially given kovid uh you know it's
hard to predict when things will get
better but we the chemicals needed at
the plant are have gone up exponentially
as well uh during covert covid uh
between just being able to get some of
this work done uh contract work uh and
to get materials again the supply chain
issues we were forced to defer some
maintenance during during covid uh we
don't want to defer longer the the a
putting off today to tomorrow is not a
good strategy to save money uh
unfortunately in a lot of these cases so
this really is is our biggest
prioritized need that you know we have
an obligation to run these plans for the
community as the communities as a state
and this unfortunately this increase is
needed in order to make that happen so
um that's our biggest biggest ask uh in
our prioritized needs I can stop there
and keep going I don't representative so
it says
funding mix it says a hundred percent
other
correct what's the other so again this
everything that happens at that plan is
funded through those communities and
their rates they're expecting this uh
again so this has all been vetted
through that their boards uh and is
they're already a lot of the communities
have their own collection systems and
then feed to our collection system so
they they've actually started uh
assuming this is going to happen and
started embedding this because again I
think nobody wants to pay higher rates
but they understand that if you don't
fix something now it it doesn't get
cheaper later
representative McGuire What's the total
budget in this group so what kind of
percent increases is this 1.3
um for women this
um would be a 25 increase in the rate in
the cost of our budget if you have the
budget open it's page 694.
so the users will find see a 25 higher
bill
we do not
charge for the
um so we're not sure what their rate
increases will be because they have in
addition to feeding into the system they
have pieces that are their own as I
mentioned those those entities also have
their own collection systems and their
own staff and that all feeds us so it's
hard to answer that so certainly yes
that's a an increase in that a 25
increase in that portion of their budget
and again we don't do that lightly but
we don't really see a lot of choice okay
thank you representative Sweeney has a
question thank you Mr merch on that same
topic so would the towns that have
budget meeting have to vote
to increase their rates and pay for part
of this or would that just be dealt with
their select boards setting the rates
I believe I don't know let me ask Mr
Pelletier if I could so it may depend on
how the town's set up yeah I think
I think most of these whenever they have
rates depending on their local structure
they go to town meeting and it'll have a
discussion and I would like to note that
of this 25 increase that Susan was
talking about the average household
increase caused by the Basin just the
Basin not their infrastructure costs is
probably around two dollars
per user
so
is like Bob explained almost like
Laconia is 50 of our flow but we have 60
miles of pipeline to get to Franklin all
of the other infrastructure is owned by
the 10 municipalities so a lot of their
piping
they're responsible for yet we have 60
miles of collection pipe that they all
connect to
yeah so
this number is more like one dollar per
everyone in New Hampshire right there's
a 1.4 million people in New Hampshire so
if the Lakes Region or the people in
those 10 communities that are using this
right they've got to be 10 or less of
New Hampshire so it's really got to be
at least ten dollars a person kind of
thing right
just our cost when you look at what we
charge the increase over what they've
been paying us is not anywhere near ten
dollars
oh monthly yes okay
well yeah it's okay thank you
I'm trying to bear with me
further questions on this side well I
would just say I'm I'm all right with
this I think that they need it in order
to operate their wastewater treatment
and it's really up to the communities to
deal with it
right the division's pleasure everybody
okay with that
an ad Mr Hoffman and Melissa please
okay item a on page 15 right
item a that's correct so it
and on page 14 they'll have the numbers
of budget page numbers 693 to 694.
all right Solid Waste program contracts
so again we have two online landfills as
I mentioned I call them orphans that
there there is no responsible party for
and this line item again it's roughly
sixty thousand dollars a year but it is
from the general fund uh they ask uh is
to to basically to to get conduct
maintenance and modern monitoring to
keep those uh in line so we have some
some idea what's going on with those and
keep those from becoming a problem so I
I don't like the idea as staff will know
of Orphan landfills but we feel a
responsibility to make sure those two
communities are not impacted
representative Griffin has a question I
I guess I'd like to know how we end up
with them often
landfilled with no responsible party
that is a
a great question
I'm sure that it is a good question and
these two particular landfills one of
them um was abandoned the owner died and
through the uh the dissolution of the
estate this essentially became an
abandoned piece of property
um it needs to have some groundwater
monitoring done and some basic cap
maintenance we are working to try to
find a solution and an owner for the
site and a use for the site where a
private owner would take care of the
responsibilities but in the meantime we
need to make sure that we understand the
conditions at the landfill to ensure
that it's not posing a risk to any
nearby residents or what have you and
then the other one is a landfill that
was
it's a very complicated story it's the
dummy yard landfill in Berlin and
success It's associated with the former
paper mills it went through a bankruptcy
there was a trust established that
provided a modest amount of money for
its care and feeding if you will it's
you know I mean it's the cap and
monitoring but that money has since
um has since been expended and there's
no more money and no responsible party
that we can look to there were some
agreements the state made going way back
that
could read that we we we're not sure we
can say we just don't want to do this
plus we obviously once again we want to
make sure that the facility isn't posing
any risk to the nearby properties and
Residences
representative
if this isn't appropriated what happens
we just aren't monitored right it'd be
difficult for us to I don't know I'm not
sure how we'd get that work done
representative Sweeney thank you so just
want Clarity so it says maintenance and
monitoring I'm not a I can't imagine
we're taking two landfills
rehabilitating the land for future use
like they're going to stay as unused no
sir this is very modest work this is
just making sure when the landfill is
closed typically it gets capped at the
very least if not with the synthetic
cover with a appropriate soil cover and
you know wood Chucks and things to play
around with that and so there's a
certain amount and you have to mow it um
you should vegetate the cap so there's a
certain amount of Maintenance of a soil
cap that's needed in order to ensure
that it continues to do what what the
cap is intended to do is essentially to
limit the amount of rain water
infiltration of the landfill so you
reduce the amount of
um uh leachate that's collected in the
potential impact slave that the landfill
can have on groundwater
representative Schultz so you mentioned
Berlin is where one of those are do you
mind naming where the other one is oh
yes it's uh in Danbury New Hampshire
all right the division's pleasure on uh
Solid Waste program contracts
so yeah
everybody okay with that
all right
yeah thanks
so C
Administration and support the main
issue is
if you set a precedent that that you can
walk away from your landfill and the
state will take care of it right you
know but that's the main problem I think
the department and justice department
has been pretty aggressive in the past
right and holding people responsible
where there's someone to hold
responsible is that correct and not to
be trite but the one in Danbury the
owner died and you know I'm not sure
there's a harsher penalty than that
was that what happens with Des
problem is since these are unlined
landfills if there is a lot of pollution
coming out of them then who deals with
that so it's
anyway too bad they're orphans all right
moving right along commissioner so the
last ask we have is again this is a mix
of funding but it is 53 Journal funds uh
is for uh there are many of our front
desk we are we are looking to upgrade a
position to full-time uh and what we've
seen is there's that expectation in the
public we try to do a lot online clearly
and and whatnot but we for obvious
reasons I hope you all agree we have a
front desk there at Hazen drive and when
somebody comes in we want a live body to
answer their questions and help them and
that's been a little bit problematic so
we're looking to to do this uh with this
increase
we okay with this
everybody
all right
small ones all add up representative
McGuire
all right now
foreign
so moving to budget adjustments so again
these are all uh
no cost yeah we'll quickly ask some
Carlson to do that
uh yes essentially
um the first
um the first two items
um we are moving um the P2 which is
pollution prevention and the Small
Business technical assistant programs
those two programs were until
um right now housed in the
Commissioner's Office what we're doing
is sending those two programs part of it
back to the air division part of it back
to the waste division so we're just
taking the accounting units and moving
them out of one the commissioner's
office and sending some of it back to
the air and some of it back to to waste
and it is detailed on the technical
adjustment sheet here
um so that you can see the pluses and
minus it's a zero-sum game to our budget
it just is moving them between divisions
um the coastal resiliency infrastructure
program we are simply moving money
between classes when we set up the
budget back in August
um we anticipated 2.8 million dollars
um in class 85 for interagency Grant
transfers
um with prices as they are we understand
there's going to be a price increase so
we're decreasing the contract line by
125 000 in 24 and increasing the
interagency transfer line by 125 so it's
again another zero-sum game
the state air permit program which is
the last of our ass
um
this is a correction and I must
apologize to the committee I should have
had it fixed in the governor's phase and
I just didn't get to it
what is happening is
um
this is an idiosyncrasy of the um the
bars system
which is the state's budgeting system we
had put on a prioritized need to this
account to partially fund this account
by 250 000 of General funds we attempted
to make this prioritized need a revenue
adjustment only
bars cannot handle a revenue adjustment
only so administrative services in order
to get this into the budget created a
class 103 contracts for operational
Services of 250 000 we're asking for
that
expenditure class to be eliminated and
to reduce the agency income by the same
amount of money
any questions on that representative
McGuire so this is really just
reflecting reality yes yeah okay
so don't run away yet we do have further
questions
so I see it was the chairman of Public
Works still back there
nice to see you sir if you'd like to sit
up here in that corner chair
so a house bill 276.
um the bacteria mitigation
what can you tell us about that
representative Ebel had asked if we
could send that to you for your advice
and wisdom
thank you Mr chairman the
we were surprised to see that uh House
Bill 276 did not come through Public
Works which is where we thought it
should have come through and then to
find out it's a 25 million dollar uh
Capital uh
uh mitigation fund that they want to set
up and we're a bit perplexed that where
our entire budget is only in the 120
million dollar range how we could ever
afford that
and so I was uh I I see absolutely
nowhere that we can find 25 million
dollars out of that budget I guess
you're no stranger to this but there
were over a billion dollars worth of
requests and you know we're down to 120
million so I I don't see that we have
room for it I understand that I don't
know what action you've taken on it and
if I should have further conversation
with you Mr chairman on that or no we
trust your guidance that we're hearing
right now sir okay
that's why we thought it should head
over to you it seemed like a more
appropriate place for it we try to send
anything that with a major policy or
something that should be in another
committee there first to get a read
because we're supposed to be just
looking at the numbers okay we try to
hold by that we appreciate that and we
appreciate the courtesy of referring it
over to us well not at all however that
process will happen we won't get out of
here without a question from
representative McGuire well no I'm going
to say let me give you a statement so
earlier today we decided to retain this
bill because of the problematic funding
and then look at it this one we're
really going to look at it over the
summer and figure out where we can find
money for it how much is needed all that
sort of stuff because effectively this
bill is borrowing money and giving it
away in Grants right and that doesn't
really make sense so you know that
that's the idea representative McGuire I
agree with your approach okay thank you
very good thank you thank you so much
thanks
so on another note
um I know Mr Wimsatt will appreciate
this perhaps
uh the division did support unanimously
the uh two million dollars for the solid
waste management fund to be put in the
budget
thank all you for helping representative
evil with that
um anything else that the division has
representative Sweeney sorry I not a
problem uh 212 on the pfas
fund yeah if if if we can get uh either
a one-pager or a spreadsheet of where
the current fund is what is going to
lapse over the next year there was
mention of six million dollars lapsing
this year
um and just what the trajectory and
projections are for them
so thank you
so too yes this is the one you were
doing yeah yeah it was coming back in
brief if I may in brief answer to your
question yes that was requested at your
session on Friday and we'll have that
letter for you probably tomorrow it'll
be coming over
I know we spoke about representative
Evil's two million dollars I thought no
but it was HP 300 the one on the food
waste we voted to include oh okay okay
okay
not to jump ahead that was like 78 000.
and I was very happy
I can't I can't take it back I'm afraid
the woman to my right here
so all right well thank you very much
for your presentation and if you could
get that information to the LBA was just
representative Sweeney's question
answered that'd be great
and thank you for your time I don't see
a need to have you come back so
I will let you know obviously if you do
we're happy to come back thank you
so we'll open up the budget Works
session on the Department of Business
and economic Affairs and I see the
commissioner here
we have a package and we'll let you
take it away and just looking to see
let's see what page
economic affairs
you're on page 545 for those
looking at the budget
all right commissioner it's all yours to
well uh Mr chairman thank you for having
us I I don't have a whole ton of
prepared remarks just because we have
had a conversation just about two weeks
ago about the department itself and what
we do
um you know I think from the standpoint
just a brief overview uh the Department
of Business and economic Affairs has
within it two main divisions the
division of travel tourism development
and the division of Economic Development
we have also within us a number of other
organizations and offices including the
office of outdoor recreation industry
development the office of Workforce
opportunity the office of international
Commerce so we do a lot of work in the
International Space in creating markets
for New Hampshire businesses and working
with those businesses to access those
markets and we have uh you know maybe
another couple of other offices
including our administrative office
so when we look at the budget that we
have here today we don't have a real a
very significant increase of requests
over our previous biennium we don't have
any sort of like major changes within
that budget from the last biennium I
think as far as positions go we current
we currently have around 76
positions listed uh in our budget
um and we have a a requesting for two
funding two additional positions one
both within our administrative office
um I would say really those are kind of
the highlights but I'm certainly here to
be able to discuss or to go into detail
on any subjects related to the
Department of our or our budget that you
uh that you want to bring up today
well they're always budget questions do
you have a budget in front of you or I
do okay
representative Maguire has a question
yes thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for coming so uh let's go to page 561
the kind of the end of the budget
um and uh these are the grand totals and
it looks like the most variability is in
your federal funds so you actually
receive 6.7 in 2022
um 2023 was was expected to be 10 I
don't know if it is or not and then and
then for the next two years you're
expecting big increases right 11.3
14.8 so what's going on with several
certainly so we have within uh ba a
number of offices that are almost
exclusively federally funded uh and each
of those are seeing increases on the
federal side so the office of Workforce
opportunity administers the Department
of Labor's Workforce Innovation and
Opportunity Act funds we owe a funds uh
the uh procurement technical assistance
center PTAC works with businesses that
are looking to access government
contracts that's funded by the
Department of Defense we have the office
of international Commerce which is
largely funded by the small business
administration through a step Grant so
each of those three right there
saw increases over the last several
years since covid and I think that's
what you're seeing reflected here
further yes but I noticed the total
number of employees is unchanging so are
most of these extra federal funds going
out back out as grants yes sir they're
programmatic funds gotcha okay now you
said you wanted two more employees is
that
unfunded employees from previously or is
it so uh yes these are positions that
were not previously funded in the last
biennium one of them is human resources
position uh which we it was a position
that we lost just before covid came in
and at that time as you'll recall we
went into a budgetary lockdown
effectively and so we did not fill that
position and we made went through the
last biennium without having funding
Associated for that while we have 76
employees a good portion of those
employees are on our rest area and
welcome center side and that does demand
a lot of a lot of effort to continue to
do all the Recruitment and all the
things that we've spoken about before
for that for that part of our office we
do also have uh some a new office the
office of planning and development that
came over as part of the Department of
energy uh split that came last biennium
that added about six employees I believe
to us so since the time that we lost
that HR position we have seen some
increase in the number of positions and
I think the HR needs are really pretty
substantial so we asked for that okay
and how many of the 76 positions are
vacant
not too many right now uh the we have as
far as our Concord staff and the
immediate policy staff I don't believe
we have any openings all of our uh
openings are on the rest area Welcome
Center side great thank you
further questions
representative Schultz
no there's never a dumb question maybe
this one is
um
I know that there has been there have in
recent years been a number of programs
to give certain industries in New
Hampshire
um an incentive for workers by forgiving
their student loans to some degree
does that money come from your
Department okay no ma'am that's uh so
that's a proposal I believe that's in
hb2 for this year and it would run
through the business Finance Authority
who we work with but it's a separate uh
entity because it was
there is a biotech one already don't
close the door because it doesn't work
it's gonna get it locked in oh
interesting nobody wants it it would be
your fault yeah
you will not make friends
it was I was under the impression that
there were already ongoing programs uh
that for example were targeted for Dean
cayman's companies but I believe they
were expanded to biotech so so I don't
know what your involvement in those type
of obviously maybe the budget is
different but you must at some degree be
involved with those type of programs
development you are correct so there is
a program that is specific for uh
companies that locate in New Hampshire
uh that are qualified under the
regenerative manufacturing uh thing so
uh companies that come to New Hampshire
and there have been a couple are
eligible to work with the business
Finance Authority uh for that benefit
and I think what you're seeing in hb2 is
a potential expansion
of that program to a broader number of
Industries
are there further questions
representative evil
so um
is it Liz Gray she's here on behalf of
the sbdc and there is a letter here that
you were hoping to increase the
appropriation from the governor's
recommended budget I didn't know
who should talk about that
well I could say uh you know we work
very closely with the Small Business
Development Center uh and with Liz and
her team our retention team
that is out in the field every day is
constantly working with sbdc we had
requested I think 500 000 per
biennium uh to to provide help provide
funding to sbdc that's a necessary part
of their uh of their funding scheme with
the number that we have in the budget
right now is I believe at 390 yes
so could you describe a little bit more
what their function is so small Business
Development Center list is probably a
better job than I do in describing this
but they work with very very small
businesses uh in a whole host of
different Industries to help those
companies
um get to a point where they uh uh can
either start a business or continue to
operate a business
um and give them assistance that is you
know of no cost to the to the uh to the
company
so where we are seeing a lot of those
businesses in our day-to-day business
operations we would generally refer them
to sbdc for additional assistance
so it's there's a very there's a very
close relationship between us
really
say would you like us to consider this
additional request it was a request that
we had made yes
so I have a question going back to uh
earlier what representative McGuire was
asking about some of the
funding I see obviously that your
general fund line has gone up for the
next biennium
pretty substantially 2.2 million and two
point a little more than 2.3 million
in for 25 could you tell us where some
of those
significant general fund or is it
um smaller amounts that just add up to a
significant amount I think it's a little
bit the former but I would also say to
remember that the funding that we put
forward for the state's tourism
marketing is reflective of the revenue
the revenue that comes in under the
meals and rentals tax so under our
statute we submit a budget that
represents 3.15 percent of those
revenues
and as a result I would say of the fine
work of Lori harnoy's and the team at
travel and tourism we have seen
increases in those Revenue numbers over
the last two years and so naturally the
number that we request and that comes
through
that we spend on the funding for that
marketing uh naturally sees an increase
in those years I would add to that that
this year the data that we have
indicates that for every dollar that we
invest in marketing the state of New
Hampshire the uh meals and rentals tax
increases by about 16 so we it's it's
one dollar for every 16 that we see in
return
where are the questions representative
McGuire
represents Sweden thank you Mr chairman
in the past when there has ever been an
economic softening do we see how long is
the
delay in seeing that impact on either
tourism or the amusement rooms Revenue
um that's one of the first places we
start to see the impact of an economic
downturn and people stop you know
spending money to to travel or to go out
to dinner so it is one of the first
places we would see an indicator of
things going down but you're I think
where you're going is that yes when we
are in a position where we see a
downturn in the level of tourism in the
state the marketing funds that we have
available to us actually also go down
one one could argue that's backwards but
I yeah that's the system that we have
and that's the way it works and so we
deal with that when that comes up thank
you appreciate it
so I'm looking commissioner at the Small
Business Development Center
funding which I believe is on page 555
and the governor's recommended amount is
000 and
so this request that we just received
would be for again the additional five
hundred thousand
it would be an additional 110. okay
that's what we had requested
so they're 500 000 is here
total watch not an additional watch
correct
return on investment they it looks
pretty good here
all right any further questions
we do have a number of House Bill 2
items I think I saw
your department
listed next to and while we're going
there
you have a role in invest New Hampshire
is that right yes sir
so tell us what that's about because
there's a pretty significant want for
that yes so if SNH is a program that ba
has been operating since the summer of
2022. this is a total of 100 million
dollars that was allocated to Bea for
the purposes of addressing affordable
Workforce housing in the state we have
divided that fund into a number of
different programs the first program is
the capital grant program and that was a
a program that has been underway since
awards were approved by the executive
Council in early November of
2022. those are funds that are designed
for affordable housing that that is a
rental in nature new build already
underway these funds were designed to
help supplement the resources to those
programs to those projects to be able to
get those units online more quickly we
are currently operating that program and
funds are being dispersed under that
program the other program has to do with
support for municipalities as part of
the addressing the housing crisis within
that are three programs the first
program is a Planning and Zoning grant
program to help communities that choose
to look at their planning and zoning
rules whether they want to update those
or they want to look at making changes a
lot of times the cost of doing that
through a consultant or otherwise is a
prohibitive cost on that municipality so
these funds are made available for them
to be able to accomplish that there are
also funds that we are currently
dispersing that are related to the
demolition of of properties in a
municipal reality that would assist in
improving the housing situation in that
Community we're seeing the first round
of those funds starting to disperse now
and then the final program is designed
for municipalities who
are permitting these types of Workforce
housing units in their community and
allowing them to apply for
a grant in the amount of ten thousand
dollars per unit of of permitted units
in their communities and that those
grants are pretty flexible in terms of
what they can be used for so all that
total is uh is a hundred million dollar
program now what's an hb2
I'm sorry go ahead everybody's trying to
find this it's page 20 sections 40 45 to
47 ish
thank you for that representative
yeah I should if you need me to stop
just start waving sometimes I get going
invest New Hampshire started on page 19.
was section 43. okay
so under hb2 there is a request for 30
million dollars uh to that would
effectively go toward the
um the first program that I was
described in the capital grant program
uh when we ran that program uh we gave
30 Awards
to projects all around the state we had
150 applications most of which I would
say 90 of those were eligible projects
so we really felt that there was a
substantial need that still existed for
that type of funding and so the governor
included 30 million dollars in his
budget to effectively do a second round
of that program
and again this is all General funds yes
sir
previous 100 million was all arpa funds
oh yes representative Schultz thank you
so when you by the way I'm very happy
that you're not just talking about
so-called Workforce housing which I
assume to be at the higher end pay but
you also are talking about affordable
housing because you can't have one
without the other correct by way of a
market
you also need workers who don't make
higher wages so but what is the
definition or sort of cut off as we
continue to have that conversation do
you have a like um a press a price point
for rentals or houses in mind we do so
we use a a figure that equates to 80 of
the area median income or below
so in order to be eligible for the funds
under the program that I described the
the capital grant program uh the units
that are being funded have to uh be at
80 or below
yes sir
great thank you
further questions
on this item 45 and post bill 2.
we will take a hard look at this
okay what else is PDA here
Melissa Mr Hoffman I'll go ahead
representative thank you so so there
seems to be two similar ones the the
affordable housing fund 25 million and
invest in age 30 million so how do they
oh right how do they differ so the
affordable housing fund is a fund that
is administered by New Hampshire Housing
Finance Authority and so last I believe
in the last biennium
um there was also a very similar
provision to provide 25 million dollars
to um to capitalize that program uh this
would do that same thing again so not
within Bea but under New Hampshire
housing
that's the 25 the 30 is for for the the
invest in age is the 25 loans or is it
no I I I'm I'm not 100 certain exactly
how they use the funds but I do know
that it is a grant program that they use
to help supplement uh projects that they
fund under the low income housing tax
credit program so good the the same
organization get grants from both
of course yes
and that's not a I should say that's not
atypical in the world of Housing
Development uh oftentimes when you're
talking about projects that have
anywhere between 15 or 500 units there
are multiple funding sources that are
used in order to achieve that across a
whole host of state and federal entities
another question yes thank you I and I I
thought I heard you say that to apply
this has to be an existing project in
some sense the project's already started
well yes so we wanted basically shovel
ready projects we didn't want and again
under the under the I should reiterate
that under arpa we have to have all
funds obligated by the end of 2024 and
we have to have all funds expended by
the end of 2026. so in the world of
development construction that's not far
away so we weren't looking to to use
those funds to get into projects that
are just now you know getting in the
ground we needed projects that were
experiencing funding shortfalls either
in their Capital stack or through
inflationary costs that you know of
supplies or labor costs or something so
we were looking for projects that had
already been permitted and and to some
degree were ready to to Begin work
immediately so that they could be done
in time to expend those under the arpa
deadlines but these new things that's
not our this is that's correct General
funds that's right we don't have those
kind of considerations thank you
questions representative people no I
don't I was just looking at
Melissa yes
sure I have a few of them to go through
if you want a couple of them we can
start uh section 40 which is the office
of regulatory review reduction in
government efficiency yes uh so this is
a uh that's page 16.
thank you myself this is a program that
the governor has asked to have
administratively attached to Bea it's
not a program or Pro or a uh or a unit
of government that we would have
necessarily authority over but the idea
with this is to look at
um state regulations that are
administered by state agencies from the
perspective of an employer whether
that's a for-profit or non-profit
employer and be able to have some degree
of input on behalf of those employers
as part of the rulemaking process it
also allows for an opportunity for
the state to look at the way that
different let's say big picture
programs and initiatives are
administered so for example
um you know child care where there might
be multiple agencies that are involved
in in initiatives that are designed to
help address the child care issue in the
state this would allow this organization
to take a look at all of those programs
how they interact with each other and
seek to improve the interaction of that
and that's the government efficiency
side of things so
that's really sort of the overview of
this
um there that I think there is a
provision for three or four staff people
to administer this office and again I
would say the role of ba is purely from
an administrative standpoint to help
this entity meet their needs uh from an
administrative standpoint
so the sum of 750 000 that would be
all General funds pretty soon now do you
have a budget with any breakdown of the
750 uh I do not but I could tell you
that it would be almost all exclusively
for salaries maybe with you know with
the supporting costs for technology and
so on but it would just be basically in
that category
area we'll take a look at that yeah
represent Maguire so on page 17 line of
the House Bill 2 line 18 there's a
section here that says the objective
scoring criteria
Etc what are the what is being scored
what are they talking about so I that's
a mechanism that was designed to be able
to uh allow this entity to look at new
regulations from the standpoint of a
scoring Matrix that they would
themselves develop in order to measure
the potential
a positive or negative impact of those
regulations
it's I believe it's designed to be just
basically a prioritization system
for other questions representative
all right Melissa next
sure I think the last part is on page
five
um there's just some various Provisions
from section 58 to section 63.
if like repeals Department of DEA
Department of B it looks like cleanup
language yeah so these last Provisions
are are related to
um sort of the ongoing development over
time since we split dread up there were
a number of Provisions that carried into
our statute that we really don't have
any have no operational function
so we just wanted to clean those up and
made that request
so just clean up
so this man sure absolutely yeah so this
new chapter 12 piece stuff is all about
rulemaking and so I'd like to ask Carol
about it and give comments sorry oh
absolutely so we'll ask representative
Carol Maguire to take a look at this
section
take care of that representative
or something yeah write a very detailed
letter
yeah
question sure so on page 83 then section
258 so you're repealing programs New
Hampshire grip micro Enterprise Relief
Fund
those are those are programs that came
up during covid uh that we haven't
really been able sought to operate and
have not been successful in their
operation or have not been necessary so
the covid-19 micro Enterprise program
um when we when we ran the at the state
level the Main Street Relief Fund and
the gap program and the cell phone so
those programs generally took care of
those populations so they were passed
and they were included in our statute
um but in the end we felt pretty
strongly that those resources had been
deployed effectively to the same
populations
over there nope
so was it just 258 you have to vote on
what we're going to do
it's 258 through 263.
63.
we're going to ask the
Edna committee to take a look
votes items
Melissa you got that those several items
will ask Edna
I don't
just policy
there was a Sweeney my name is Chairman
so I do have a question about the letter
from sbdc so it states that if the if we
were to do the additional funding to get
it to 500 000 uh they would likely hire
a full-time business advisor to support
the Biotech Industry can we can we just
go over the need for that I'm sort of
so I I'm aware of Army and other larger
players in the field but in terms of
other businesses emerging in the biotech
what is the role a business advisor
these seem like established firms that
would have a business advisor of their
own I I would say uh that first off that
biotechs and life science sector is one
of the fastest growing in the state
right now and so what we're seeing is
yes there are larger companies like
lonza where some of the programs that
are running through the Army project in
Manchester absolutely but what they are
doing is spinning off a lot of of other
companies that are in that same space
and looking to take advantage of the
resources the workforce that we're
seeing that's increasing in New
Hampshire as it relates to this space
and the access to the workforce just to
our Southern border of people who maybe
want to come in the other direction so
we do see a substantial
um Competitive Edge that we uh can take
advantage of in New Hampshire to help
grow this industry
Statewide and we've seen for example at
least one company that has chosen to
locate its U.S headquarters in Keene and
associate with Keene State College so
they do seek to be near research centers
whether it's our academic centers or in
some cases our community colleges but
the ability for the state through sbdc
and through ba to be able to facilitate
that activity is definitely a priority
for the Department
follow-up sure thank you so I I agree
completely with the growing biotech this
does say it would just be for the
greater Manchester region and it seems
like we would need such a role Statewide
for the Keynes for Seacoast with lonza
and so I well I don't want to speak for
for Miss gray but I think uh you know uh
the Army project itself is throwing off
a substantial amount of this activity
and it is not necessarily always
specifically around regenerative
medicine or regenerative manufacturing
it is around a space that takes that
same sort of skill set of an individual
in a Workforce and it brings them to New
Hampshire we're looking at companies
that are seeing that value and May and
are increasingly willing to make an
investment in New Hampshire so yes there
is a bit of an epicenter that's
occurring in Manchester but again as I
as I mentioned we have a very strong
relationship with sbdc so whatever work
is being done in that space is something
that's going to be shared with our team
at Bea that then does go Statewide and
there's nothing to say that at some
point as we continue to see growth in
that sector that they would go beyond
just the purely Manchester space thank
you very much
so I know there are some questions on
ARP right now that we've got there
should I moved to this seat over here
it's a question I mean I just it keeps
coming up maybe we can use arpa funds
for this and maybe we can use arpa funds
for this and everybody says it with
great hope and Glee yeah but um you know
there are several infrastructure
projects for instance that are being
proposed so we thought what better
person to ask about it and you so Youth
Development Centers right but there are
other buildings in here so uh just in in
the at the very highest level I guess
um right now you're gonna under arpa
there are a number of different funding
programs the one that gopher the
organization that I run in my spare time
is uh what is responsible for What's
called the state fiscal recovery funds
so those are among the most flexible
arpa funds that the state received the
total we received under that program was
around 990 million dollars
uh we received that now back in
2021 as I recall so uh as of our latest
work with the joint fiscal committee uh
we are we have crossed over 920 million
dollars that has been obligated into
that program so what that basically
means is that we are rapidly approaching
um uh the end of uh available funds to
obligate under the sfrf
you've heard me talk a lot about
Broadband uh that is another program
that we receive funding under arpa under
a separate program called the capital
projects fund uh that is one of the
infrastructure type Investments that we
are able to make under arpa and that is
separate from this this fiscal Recovery
Fund
um and it that total is 122 million
dollars we have a cat we have obligated
um virtually all of that fund at this
point for Broadband Investments but I
would say on the Broadband thread there
is and and relevant to the discussion is
uh there are also funds that the federal
government is providing under what they
initially call the iija or the
infrastructure investment something
something act uh and has is now called I
think the bipartisan infrastructure law
but in any case there will be additional
funds that the state will receive for
Broadband under that program and so when
we start to talk about infrastructure
and the Investments that are needed to
be made there
most of the funding that will be
available from the federal government
for these recovery type of
resources will be under the iija funding
that is going to be primarily
administered by the Department of
Transportation so gopher does not have a
role with iija we are exclusively the
sfrf people and I'm sorry to kill you
with acronyms but that's uh when we deal
with the federal government we tend to
see a lot of them
so if we could get a definitive answer
as far as like the Youth Development
Center there's folks have said we can
get our upper funds and as you probably
know the figure that's being tossed
around is about 21 million is that
realistic to anticipate we could get our
profunds for this it's hard to say and I
would have to go back and check with the
Gopher staff and see exactly what's in
the pipeline right now and whether that
is in the pipeline I don't know that
right off the top of my head
um but
um I will say on the Gopher website you
can get a you can get a list of all of
the funds that fiscal committee has and
programs and projects that have been
approved there and broken out by
specific areas so whether they're
infrastructure or so on a good portion
of the funds early on that we made were
in the infrastructure category for water
and sewer Investments and again we made
those Investments very early because of
the runway that's necessary for
infrastructure projects and recognizing
that we have an end date for the use of
the arbor funds
so
there's 70 million dollars left right so
does it have to really so it doesn't
have to relate to covid and I'm trying
we're trying to understand what some of
the guard rails are on the use of the
money I mean I'd be happy to send you
several of the funding requests in here
for buildings for instance yes
so uh
treasury the Department of Treasury in
Washington gives us literally dozens of
expenditure categories that all have you
know and we have to qualify each
individual program and project under uh
and that's increasingly the role that
gopher plays is to just make sure that
we are within the eligible spending
categories and expenditure categories
that we report on regularly to the
federal government
so uh yes the program is designed to be
a covered recovery uh and and relief
program but at the same time they do
allow some pretty substantial
investments in things like
infrastructure in things like Economic
Development health care and so on where
we've been seeing those resources put
over the last two years under arpa
so it is uh it is in its impetus a
covert recovery program but it is a
loose connection in some cases
[Music]
building or something we would ask you
whether that was
something that we could use the money
for would you have to check with
Washington or there's just
process is very confusing so that's
really the again the role of the of the
Gopher team and we have a team of I
think we're about eight or nine people
right now and their job is just as what
you're saying we get a constant influx
of requests both from within government
and outside of government and you know
the role that gopher plays is to look at
all of those
requests look at programs that are
currently in existence look at the
eligibility categories in expenditure
categories look at the budgets and the
types of programs that are being
requested work with agencies to identify
if those agencies are are able to deploy
and Implement and comply with the
regulations under each one of these
resources and these these different
programs and then you know then we work
with joint fiscal committee and the
executive Council to move those programs
forward
on the back end we our team also works
with U.S treasury on on the compliance
component of this and the good deal of
federal reporting that goes on on a
quarterly basis that is in great detail
of where each dollar is being spent and
how those funds are meeting all the
compliance requirements so it's it's a
fairly significant undertaking
so do you folks then make the
recommendations on how to deploy the
funds based on the requests you get
uh again what we do is we sort of do the
Baseline work of making sure all of the
pieces are in place and then we work
with fiscal committee and make that
presentation it's not always us that
does it so in some cases you might have
HHS or other departments that come
forward with funds that are looking to
use the sfrf funds under arpa and then
that's the process it goes through they
go through the normal process
maybe I'll send you a couple of our
buildings and you can take a look at
them
so so you're not aware of the Department
of Health and Human Services making a
request
to go for yet for their new facility or
ah just because I don't know about it
doesn't mean it hasn't happened so
that's why I
um I want to make sure that I check on
that and I can get back to you
I know that representative Edwards would
be very pleased I think your Deputy was
here before the full committee last week
and the request was made to get a
definitive answer whether there could be
Arbor funds or other funds for that
facility okay those two pieces are
connecting now so let me check with him
and just sort of see where things stand
and we can get back to you thanks very
much are there further questions for the
commissioner
seeing now we do have a few questions
and we'll get back to you on some of
those additional ads great thank you
very much thank you everybody
I think we're good I just wanted to
expand
um if you could do sections 258 to 265.
I'm just going to add a couple of
sections that need to go to Edna okay
yeah represent McGuire will
deal with that thank you yes yeah
Carol's been reading through that entire
thing and she's got a few changes
all right we'll see you at session
tomorrow
10 o'clock I think she's through about
100 pages